parti des négociations vu des élections
2014 donc on est on est aussi dans la
préparation de ces élections et de de
savoir si ce va de vraies élections FR
naationales ou pas pour la première fois
avec comme en jeu la désignation du
président de la Commission européenne on
retourne à Strasbourg où la séance à
l'air de bienvenue aussi au ministre des
affaires étrangères de la République
française Laurent Fabius bienvenue
monsieur le
ministre et notre collègue qui travaille
régulièrement ensemble avec nous le
ministre des affaires europé monieur
Bern bienvenue monsieur le
ministreche par exordinaire pour le
Parlement
EUR que de recevoir le président de la
République
française au sein de notre
institution président Hollande le fait à
titre de chef d'État il a déclaré qu'il
était disposé à titre d'autes politiques
de notre Assemblée a participé à un
débat avec le Parlement européen ce qui
est tout à fait inédit monsieur le
Président ça n'a pas encore existé
jusqu'ici et c'est sans doute une
novation intéressante pour le Parlement
européen je vais vous donner la parole
tout d'ordur
chef d'état d'un merveilleux pays celui
où nous siégeons ici à
Strasbourg je donne la parole au
président de la République française
Monsieur François
Hollande merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président du
Parlement é cher Martin
Schultz monsieur le Président de la
Commission
européenne mesdames messieurs les
députés je vous remercie de l'honneur
que vous me faites en me permettant de
m'exprimer ici à
Strasbourg devant le Parlement
européen la France respecte le rôle et
la place de votre assemblée dans
l'ensemble des institutions
européennes je m'adresse à vous vous
comme le représentant d'une nation qui a
lié son destin à celui de
l'Europe et qui porte encore
aujourd'hui une responsabilité
particulière je m'adresse à vous comme
un homme politique dont la conviction
européenne a guidé son
engagement je m'adresse à vous comme un
chef d'État qui a placé la réorientation
de l'Europe au cœur de son action
et qui se consacre depuis 9 mois à cette
tâche je m'adresse à
vous comme le président d'une république
dont la promesse depuis 200 ans est de
faire que la génération suivante vive
mieux que la
précédente
l'Europe est une formidable
idée une immense
aventure construction politique
exceptionnelle
elle a réussi à faire l'histoire sans
défaire les nations
elle a produit un modèle
envi sur tous les continents
elle a instauré la paix les droits de
l'homme la démocratie ce que le prix
Nobel a juste raison est venu
consacrer mais depuis trop longtemps
l'Europe doute d'elle-même hésite sur
ses choix pratique tantôt la fuite en
avant tantôt l'immobilisme
elle met trop de temps à prendre des
décisions
majeures celles qui sont attendues
espéré et elle met trop peu de temps à
réfléchir à ses
orientations et à son architecture
d'ensemble l'Europe elle sonore d'être
un grand marché mais elle le défend mal
face aux concurrences déloyales elle
laisse sa monnaie
l'euro vulnérable à des évolutions
irrationnelles dans un sens ou dans un
autre enfin l'Europe est un continent où
la croissance est trop faible où un
chômage de masse révèle la profondeur de
la crise qui n'est pas seulement comme
on l'a dit une transition
passagère mais une mutation profonde et
s'il est vrai que la crise de la zone
euro est désormais largement derrière
nous nous sommes loin d'en avoir tiré
toutes les
conséquences et ce qui nous menace
aujourd'hui n'est plus la défiance des
marchés c'est celle des peuples et qui
ne voit à travers une suite de
déclaration que l'intérêt national est
en train de prendre le pas sur l'intérêt
EUR
européen alors la question que les chefs
d'État et de gouvernement comme le la
Commission européenne comme le Parlement
européen ont à résoudre et la
suivante c'est pas une question d'un
moment c'est la question de notre propre
avenir comment faire pour retrouver
l'adhésion
pour faire ressurgir l'envie
d'Europe et d'abord comment faire pour
ever le défi de la stabilité financière
et de la croissance
économique je veux saluer
depuis plusieurs mois les efforts qui
ont été engagés et les avancées qui ont
été obtenues sur ces
terrainlà l'Europe a été capable de se
doter de moyens
indispensables pour garantir le sérieux
budgétaire et je veux rendre hommage au
Parlement européen qui a
contribué largement à travers le sixpac
et le
TAC les états eux-mêmes ont ratifié le
traité budgétaire et la
France mon autorité en a pris la
responsabilité mais
parallèlement le Conseil européen de
juin dernier a également décidé d'un
pacte de croissance en harmonie avec les
orientations du Parlement
européen cette Europe qui été jugée trop
lente a été également capable de mettre
en place des instrument de stabilité de
solidarité notamment le Mécanisme
Européen de
Stabilité enfin la Banque centrale
européenne a redéfini ses interventions
en annonçant clairement ses intentions
face au visés
spulative et ainsi le calme est revenu
sur les marchés et les intérêt sur
certaines d'autes dettes souveraines ont
pu
baisser nous avons aussi permis à la
Grèce de rester dans la zone euro quand
certains avaient déjà trop vite annoncé
son
départ enfin les principes d'une union
bancaire ont été définis pour prévenir
les dérives d'un système financier et là
encore ce sera un enjeu considérable la
supervision bancaire un MC de résolution
et des épargnants mieux protégés par une
garantie de dépôt l'Europe a été capable
de progrès mais en même temps elle ne
peut en rester
là car à mes yeux il n'y aura pas de
répis tant que 27 millions
d'Européens seront au chômage il n'y
aura pas de répis tant que dans certains
pays de l'Union un jeune sur deux
cherche un emploi
il n aura pas de rép tant que des
millions de personnes
resteront jeté dans la
précarité il n'y aura pas de rép tant
qu'il n'y aura pas eu la définition
d'une transition énergétique capable de
nous faire passer d' d'un monde à un
autre c'est le défi de la croissance et
de l'emploi que nous devons relever il
passe sûrement
nécessairement par le désendettement et
l'amélioration de la
compétitivité mais je le dis ici devant
vous cette politique aussi nécessaire
soit-elle doit être adapté aux
situations nationales et appliqué avec
discernement dans la durée sinon nous
condamnerions l'Europe à l'austérité
sans fin et je m'y
refuse la France elle-même a pris des
engagements elle les tiendra
mais en même temps nous devons
collectivement et constamment ajuster
nos objectifs au réalité de la
conjoncture la prochaine étape que nous
devons ouvrir c'est la coordination des
politiques économiques national c'est
nécessaire pour résorber les
déséquilibres il y a des pays qui ont
des
excédents qui ont une compétitivité
élevée d'autres qui ont des déficits qui
ont des efforts à faire et bien les pays
qui sont dans la première situation
doivent relancer leur demande intérieure
pour permettre aux autres de pouvoir
connaître un moment le retour de
l'activité de la même manière nous
devons réfléchir à la place de notre
monnaie l'euro dans le monde
elle ne peut fluctuer selon les humeurs
du
marché une zone monétaire doit avoir une
politique de change sinon elle se voit
imposer une parité qui ne correspond pas
à l'état réel de son économie il ne
s'agit pas dans ce propos d'assigner de
l'extérieur un objectif à la Banque
centrale européenne qui est indépendante
mais d'engager l'indispensable réforme
du système monétaire
international car sinon nous demandons à
des pays de faire des efforts de
compétitivité qui sont anilés par la
valorisation de
l'euro le moment est venu de lancer le
grand chantier de l'approfondissement de
l'Union économique et monétaire la
France y est prête
elle a deux principes l'intégration et
la solidarité
l'intégration c'est la définition
d'objectifs partagé c'est
l'harmonisation des politiques fiscales
l'intégration ce sont des réformes
structurelles pour rendre nos économies
plus fortes mais également des
politiques communes en matière
d'infrastructure de recherche
l'intégration ce sont nouveaux
instruments financiers pour lancer des
projets innovants en matière de nouvell
technologies en matire d'énergie
renouvelable en matière de transition
énergétique et
écologique et puisque nous sommes pour
l'intégration nous sommes pour la
solidarité car l'une ne va pas sans
l'autre la solidarité ce n'est pas
seulement le transfert
entre nation
européenne la solidarité c'est une
ambition sociale c'est de garantir à
chaque jeune européen un emploi ou une
formation à la fin de ces études en
renforçant les échanges entre les
étatmemb la solidarité c'est la lutte
contre le chômage notamment dans les
territoires le plus
durement c'est l'enjeu notamment du fond
d'adaptation à la
mondialisation la solidarité ce sont les
transition professionnelle c'est
d'accompagner les salariés tout au long
de leur parcours leur permettre de
garder leur droit à la retraite à
l'assurance chômage à la sécurité
sociale quand il change de métier et
parfois même de pays la solidarité c'est
ouvrir le chantier du salaire
minimum la solidarité ce sont aussi des
instrumen financiers à travers de
nouvelles ressources à travers la taxe
sur les transactions
financières à travers tout ce qui peut
permettre d'imaginer l'avenir
ensemble le Parlement européen de ce
point de vue a ouvert la voie vous avez
au-delà des sensibilités
politiques lancé l'idée d'emprunt commun
je l'ose pas dire de rebond mais vous
avez imaginé ce que pouvait être le
terme même de l'intégration et de la
solidarité et c'est dans cette
perspective que doit se situer la
discussion sur le cadre financier
européen et je veux m' ouvrir
directement devant vous nous connaissons
toutes les difficultés de cette
négociation les uns veulent des coupes
les autres parfois les mêmes veulent des
garanties sur leur chèqu ou sur leur
rabetis la plupart des pays sont
intéressés par telle ou telle part du
budget européen mais pas sur
l'autre alors ma position elle s'énonce
simplement faire des économies oui
affaiblir l'économie non et dès
lors notre position celle de la France
se décline en qu principes prier
principe un niveau de dépenses qui
préserve des politiques
communes d'abord la politique de
cohésion qui finance les investissements
indispensables non pas seulement pour
les pays
bénéficiaires mais pour l'ensemble de
l'Europe qui tire avantage en terme de
croissance politique commune c'est la
politique
agricole qui permet de renforcer une
industrie agroalimentaire précieuse pour
l'Union européenne mais qui doit aussi
respecter l'environnement et c'est
pourquoi les aides directes et le
développement rural sont complémentaires
mais je n'oppose pas les deux politiques
comme il est commode de le faire
politique de la cohésion contre
politique agricole nous devons garder le
socle des politiques européennes sinon
comment construire mon deuxième principe
c'est que le budget ou le cadre
financier
qui doit être proposé
doit prolonger le pacte de croissance
adopté en juin dernier ce qui suppose
d'augmenter les moyens prévus pour
l'innovation les
infrastructures les nouvelles énergies
car où serait la cohérence d'avoir
défini au mois de juin un pacte de
croissance et de faire ensuite un pacte
de déflation à travers le cadre
financier
européens mon troième
principe c'est que le budget doit
soutenir les européens les plus fragiles
et les plus exposés à la crise d'où
l'enjeu du programme d'aide au plus
démunis qui doit être non seulement
préservé mais correctement
doté de ce
fond
d'ajustement à la
mondialisation nécessaire si l'on veut
faire face aux restructurations qui
frappe de nombreux pays de la place du
Fond Social Européen dans les programmes
régionaux et enfin de l'enjeu de
l'emploi des jeunes qui doit devenir un
véritable programme européen avec une
véritable priorité pour les choix que
nous avons à
faire enfin le dernier principe que je
défendrai dans la négociation qui
s'ouvre c'est un système de ressources
qui soit plus juste et plus lisible dans
l'immédiat le montant des chècs et des
Raba doit cessé d'augmenter mais pour
l'avenir de véritables ressources
propres seront
indispensable sinon c'est la
construction européenne qui se
trouvera remise en
cause telle est la position de la
France je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
éloignée des aspiration du Parlement
européen un compromis est possible mais
il doit être
raisonnable et donc il va falloir
raisonner ceux qui veulent amputer le
budget européen au-delà de ce qu'il est
possible d'accepter car je le dis ici il
ne servirait à
rien de négocier un accord entre chef
d'État et chef de gouvernement s'il ne
devait pas être suivi par un vote
conforme de votre
assemblée chacun doit bien comprendre la
logique des institutions communautaires
et donc
vous parlementaires et les chefs d'État
et de gouvernement nous devons avec la
commission faire preuve de lucidité et
de
responsabilité voilà le sens de la
position de la France dans cette
négociation qui doit permettre à
l'Europe d'avoir un cadre d'action pour
7 ans et de montrer que nous sommes
capables de décider ensemble
chef d'État et de gouvernement
parlementaires européens c'est notre
crédibilité qui se joue crédibilité non
plus financière mais
politique Audel de ces choix budgétair
c'est une conception de l'Europe qui est
en débat et je vais vous livrer la
mienne l'EUR
elle ne peut se contenter d'être un
marché un budget une monnaie aussi
précieux soit ses
instruments elle ne peut pas non plus
être une somme de traité un ensemble de
règles
nécessaires pour vivre
ensemble l'Europe elle ne peut pas être
non plus une addition de nation chacune
venant chercher dans l'Union ce qui lui
serait utile pour elle et pour elle
seule
l'Europe parce que c'est son histoire
parce que c'est son destin est avant
tout une volonté politique c'estàdire un
engagement où chacun accepte l'équilibre
des droits et des obligation où les
règles sont respecté où la confiance
crée la solidarité c'est un projet dont
on peut pas disuter sans cesse des
acquis et remettre tout en cause à
chaque
étape en
revanche je considère
légitime de travailler à une nouvelle
architecture de l'Union
je plaide pour une Europe
différenciée selon l'expression de
Jacques Delor ce ne serait pas une
Europe à deux vitesses qui deviendrait
d'ailleurs vite une Europe inégale ou
une Europe
divisée ce n'est pas davantage une
Europe à la carte non l'Europe
différenciée c'est une Europe où des
états pas toujours les mêmes décide
d'aller de l'avant d'engager de nouveaux
projets de dégager des finances
d'harmoniser leur politique au-delà du
socle substantiel qui doit demeurer des
compétences communes mais je n'invente
rien en vous disant cela c'est cette
démarche qui a permis de dépasser les
frontières avec
Schengen de créer une monnaie unique
avec l'euro d'instituer la taxe sur les
transactions financières cette démarche
c'est la voie des coopérations renforcé
ouverte à tous à tous ceux qui veulent
le rejoindre et un jour pouvant nous
rassembler tous autour de ces principes
dans cette Europe le Parlement européen
aura un rôle majeur à jouer parce que
par son contrôle il assurera la
cohérence
d'ensemble je veux également rendre
l'Europe plus lisible j'ai plaidé pour
une intégration
budgétaire
fiscale sociale elle est là elle appelle
une union politique plus forte sinon
elle est
émiplégique ce qui veut dire un
gouvernement de la zone euro de nouveaux
instruments financiers pour agir et un
budget sous certaines condition de la
zone euro s'articulant au budget de
l'Union européenne tout cela sous le
contrôle du Parlement européen et des
parlements
nationaux je souhaite que les élections
européennes l'année prochaine
soit l'occasion d'un grand débat sur
l'avenir de
l'Europe qui permettra de déterminer les
politiques que nous aurons à conduire
sans doute mais surtout l'architecture
que nous aurons à proposer sans oublier
les candidat au postees essentiel de
notre union pour qu'il y ait une grande
délibération collective en Europe et que
l'on sorte ensuite avec une légitimité
renforcée car l'Europe elle doit avoir
les institutions qui lu permett de peser
sur le destin du monde l'Europe c'est un
continent de paix et de démocratie qui
ne cherche rien pour lui-même mais qui
apporte au reste du monde son héritage
ses valeurs ses principes et donc
l'Europe elle doit prendre sa part du
combat pour la démocratie pour la
dignité
humaine et c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai décidé au nom de la France
d'intervenir au Mali j'ai
pris j'ai pris cette décision dans le
cadre du du droit international il n'y
avait pas de temps à perdre
ou plus exactement si nous avions laissé
le temps c'était celui du
terrorisme
qui aurait en ce momentl conquis
l'ensemble du Mali je l'ai fait ce choix
au nom de la
France parce que c'était notre
responsabilité nous étions présents dans
cette région du monde nous pouvions
apporter immédiatement l'aide que le
président malien attendait de nous et
cette décision je l'ai prise aussi au
nom de l'Europe au nom de la communauté
internationale et je veux ici remercier
le Parlement européen pour le soutien et
pour la compréhension dont il a fait
preuve dans ce moment si particulier où
un pays européen s'engage pour un pays
africain et qui s'engage non plus pour
ressusciter les séqueles du passé mais
au contraire pour apporter la dignité à
un peuple qui lui-même avait permis à
mon pays d'être libéré de la servitude
durant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale j'assure ici qu'à mesure que le
Mali retrouvera son intégrité
territorial et le moment est
proche viendra le temps politique celui
du dialogue de la
réconciliation de la stabilité dans ce
pays et dans cette région de l'Afrique
de l'Ouest le temps du développement et
ce tempslà doit être celui des
organisations africaines
elles y sont prêtes elles sont déjà
présentes sur place ce doit être
aussi le temps de l'Europe parce que
nous avons à agir non seulement pour la
paix mais nous avons à agir pour la
sécurité dans cette partie là de
l'Afrique foré et équiper l'armée
malienne et les forces de la
misma permettant d'assurer la sécurité
sur le territoire d'éviter les exactions
et les règlements de comptte permettre
la transition politique le
rétablissement de la démocratie le
processus électoral l'Europe elle est
attendu aussi là pour ces raisons et
l'Europe elle est attendue également
pour participer au développement du
Sahel en tirant les leçons des
politiques qui ont été menées jusqu'à
présent et qui n pas empêcher
l'effondrement des économies de ces pays
et surtout le développement des trafics
je l'affirme ici la lutte contre le
trafic de drogue est un élément
essentiel si nous voulons lutter contre
le terrorisme parce que le terrorisme
nourrit du trafic narcotique partout
dans le monde et notamment en Afrique de
l'Ouest
nous devons aussi dans cette
redistribution des cartes de la
puissance à l'échelle du monde ne laiss
ne laisser aucun doute sur la
détermination de l'Europe apporter ses
valeurs mais nous devons en tirer là
encore les conséquences avoir la
lucidité
indispensable pour élaborer une
stratégie pour conduire une véritable
politique extérieure commune pour avoir
une défense européenne la France y est
prête il est temps là encore d'en finir
avec la dispersion des initiatives de
rassembler nos forces et nos moyens de
rapprocher nos
industries d'harmoniser aussi nos
positions dans les instances
internationales où l'Europe doit parler
d'une seule voix d'agir pour résoudre
les conflits qui heur les consciences
humaines je pense à la Syrie pour éviter
la prolifération nucléaire pense à
l'Iran pour peser sur les négociations
entre Israéliens et Palestiniens parce
que ce momentl aussi est venu et que
l'Europe ne doit pas attendre les
États-Unis mais être déjà là pour hter
la reprise de ces
discussions l'Europe
elle doit également prendre sa
part dans l'enjeu climatique et la
France est prête àan la conférence
climat en
2015 mais nons pas seul l'Europe là
encore doit être exemplaire en matière
d'énergie renouvelable et d'efficacité
énergétique je crois à
l'Europe parce que je pense qu'elle est
utile non seulement aux Européens mais
au monde tout entier et la meilleure
manière pour l'EUR de protéger ses
intérêts c'est de défendre son modèle
ses valeurs à l'échelle du monde
nous devons revenir au sens même du
projet européen qui est un projet
politique fondé sur des valeurs et sur
la circulation des personnes des
connaissances des idées des œuvres de la
culture de la création c'est en
rappelant inlassablement cette ambition
que nous serons à la hauteur de notre
histoire et surtout de l'espérance des
nouvelles générations c'est l'Europe de
la
connaissance l' europeope des
universités de la recherche de la
culture qui est
attendue nous
européens nous portons une culture qui
va bien au-delà de nous-mêmes nous
devons pas la considérer comme un
patrimoine à protéger mais comme un
mouvement à promouvoir c'est le principe
de l'exception culturelle c'est l'idée
que les œuvres de l'esprit ne sont pas
des marchandises comme les autres c'est
la conviction que l'identité culturelle
de nos nation est
essentiel et que le pluralisme la
liberté doivent être défendu à l'échelle
du monde une fois encore à cette tribune
j'appelle après d'autres la construction
européenne de se donner une dimension
culturel ce qui exige de garantir la
propriété intellectuelle et les droits
d'auteur de définir ensemble les règles
économiques et fiscales pour que les
artistes soient rémunérés davantage que
ceux qui font circuler leurs œuvres
c'est-à-dire les fournisseurs d'accès de
faire que nous ayons une Europe du
numérique où les technologies soient au
service d'un projet de civilisation
mesdames messieurs les députés François
mitteran devant le Parlement européen il
y a 17 ans 17 ans demander à ceux qui
l'écoutaient de tout faire pour que le
les Européens aiment
l'Europe 17 ans après convenons
nous sommes loin du compte et le risque
n'est plus
l'indifférence mais le
détachement pour ne pas dire la rupture
telle est notre responsabilité
regardonsla en face celle des chefs
d'État et de gouvernement celle de la
Commission
européenne celle du Parlement européen
je vous le dis tout net le sursaut il
sera collectif ou il ne sera pas mais le
temps pre
nous pouvons sortir de cette période
difficile en ouvrant un nouveau chemin
l'Europe a été capable de surmonter des
épreuve bien plus grave que celle d'une
crise mais il nous faut définir une
nouvelle ambition et cette nouvelle
ambition ne pourra
pas réduire la
précédente c'est une illusion de penser
qu'il faudrait abandonner ce que nous
avions engagé depuis des années pour
construire une nouvelle espérance au
contraire c'est de partir de tout ce que
nous avons fait pour faire ce qui reste
encore à accomplir et je sais aussi que
toute avancée européenne doit
correspondre à une nouvelle étape de la
démocratie et bien mesdames et messieurs
les
députés pour faire cette nouvelle étape
pour accomplir le projet européen pour
faire avancer la démocratie c'est vous
qui allait décider
merci
président merci Monsieur le
présidention je donne la parole à son
président José Manuel bar monur
président monsieur le Président de la
République Monsieur le Ministre Mesdames
et Messieurs les des
députés tout
d'abord je voudrais vous féliciter pour
l'organisation de ce débat monsieur le
Président de la République j'aimerais
vous féliciter pour votre discours d'une
si claire et si forte conviction
européenne c'est pour moi un plaisir de
vous répondre dans votre langue
maternelle qui n'est pas la mienne et
donc vous me m'excuserez pour certaines
erreurs mais ça me permet de vous dire
de façon plus
spontanée ce que je sens et ce que je
pense sur l'Europe et sur le rôle
exceptionnel de votre pays dans notre
projet commun de construction
européenne tout d'abord un grand merci à
la France mon nom propre et au nom de la
Commission européenne un grand merci à
la France pour tout ce que votre pays a
donné à l'Europe et au monde non
seulement par son rayonnement culturel
et
civilisationnelle mais aussi pour
l'engagement concret pour
l'approfondissement de notre projet
votre discours aujourd'hui était encore
une preuve de cette
volonté merci aussi à la France pour les
efforts aussi vos efforts personnels
pour garantir
l'intégrité et la stabilité de l'Union
économique et
monétaire comme vous l'aveiez dit ce
n'était pas évident et la France a été
toujours au côté de ceux qui voulaient
la profondissement la cohérence
l'intégration et la solidarité dans
notre union économique et
monétaire la vérité c'est que nous ne
sommes pas encore sortis de la crise
comment pourra pouriton dire que la
crise est passée quand nous avons ces
niveaux de récession et ces niveaux
intolérables de chômage dans beaucoup de
nos pays c'est pourquoi nous devons
poursuivre nos réformes sur le plan
national et aussi approfondir nos
efforts sur le plan
européen sur le plan de nos économies
national je voudrais aussi saluer la
France pour les efforts en matière
d'assaainissement des comptes publics
de réforme pour la
compétitivité de effort pour l'inversion
de la courbe du chômage et là je tiens à
souligner
l'importance de l'accord entre les
partenaires sociaux en ce qui concerne
le marché du travail qui montre la
possibilité de trouver des solutions qui
peuvent
garantir la flexibilité pour les
entreprises et la sécurité pour les
travailleurs mais il n faut faire
avantage pour approfondir l'Union
économique et monétaire pour renforcer
la gouvernance économique et je compte
sur vous pour qu'on puisse approfondir
cette union économique et monétaire tout
en
gardant l'intégrité du marché intérieur
la cohérence de l'Union dans son
ensemble et bien sûr l'assaainissement
des finances publiques les réformes pour
la compétitivité bien que nécessaire ind
dispens
elles ne sont pas suffisantes pour
garantir la croissance la croissance
depuis le début de votre mandat vous
avez à juste titre placé au centre du
débat en France et en Europe pour
garantir cette croissance soutenable
nous avons aussi besoin de
l'investissement et l'instrument le plus
important que nous avons pour
l'investissement au niveau européen
c'est précisément le budget européen
c'est
pourquoi fait un appel aux chefs d'État
et de gouvernement qui vont se réunir
cette semaine à Bruxelles pour qu'on
puisse trouver un compromis qui soit à
la mesure de l'ambition que nous avons
pour l'Europe qui nous permette
d'ppuyer qui nous permettent d'appuyer
toutes les réformes pour la
compétitivité qui nous permettent
d'appuyer l'agenda européen l'agenda
Europe 2020 tout en gardant au centre
nos préoccupations de solidarité
la cohésion la cohésion économique
sociale territoriale qui est un principe
inscrit dans nos traité en spécial le
besoin de lutter contre le chômage et
cette priorité qui est
le la lutte contre le chômage dans notre
jeunesse pour ne pas avoir une
génération
perdue il nous faut
aussi renforcer la capacité d'agir
l'Union européenne en Europe et dans le
monde comme vous l'avez AG juste titre
souligner et là pour conclure je
voudrais rendre hommage un hommage très
sincère au courage à la détermination de
la France en étant au côté du peuple du
Mali vous avez garanti que l'Europe
était aussi présente en défendant nos
intérêts et nos valeurs pour montrer que
nous avons une mission qui dépasse bien
sûr les frontières de l'Europe donc
monsieur le Président de la République
merci car vous avez apporter aujourd'hui
non seulement le volontarisme de la
France mais votre conviction personnelle
pour l'intégration et pour la solidarité
merci nous allons entamer le débat je
donne d'abord la parole au président du
Parti populaire européen Monsieur Joseph
do président du Parlement ch Martine
monsieur le Président de la répuque
monsieur le Président de la Commission
mesdames Messieurs chers collègues je
voudrais d'abord vous remercier monsieur
le Président de la République pour votre
déclaration pour votre politique
européenne mais aussi de nous permettre
d'avoir ce débat aujourd'hui si je
m'adresse à vous aujourd'hui c'est en
tant que compatriote mais avant tout en
tant que président du groupe PPE au
Parlement européen un groupe dont les
députés sont issu de 26 États membres et
à ce titre je tiens à vous dire notre
inquiétude et nous passer tout de suite
au vif du sujet nous sommes préoccupés
par les propositions du Conseil européen
sur les sur le prochain cadre financier
pluriannuel ces propositions vont dans
la mauvaise direction et au lieu
d'investir dans l'avenir de l'Europe on
s'attaque à l'un de nos meilleurs outils
de croissance le budget européen un
budget dont 94 % retourne dans les
États-membres sous forme
d'investissement des investissements qui
en plus génère un puissant levier sans
ce budget certains États-membres ne
pourraient pas mener à bien les réformes
rendues nécessaires par la crise
économique le réduire à ce point c'est
une faillite politique autant mettre la
clé sur la porte tout de suite et dire
la vérité à nos
concitoyens pour autant ne nous
méprenons pas nous ne sommes pas des
enfants gâtés nous sommes conscients des
réalités économiques et nous ne sommes
pas en train de vous soumettre une liste
de cadeaux mais nous plaidons pour un
budget qui soit crédible pour une Europe
qui se montre à la hauteur de ses
ambitions qu'elle affiche or ce n'est
pas le cas du document qui nous est
proposé à ce jour la proposition
actuelle c'est un renoncement politique
et je vous l' dis tout de suite nous
allons le rejeter monsieur le
Président il y
a jus il y a il y a plus grave on n'est
pas à 68 mon cher ami il y a plus
grave pour la première tu m'as tu m'as
appris comment il faut faire pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de l'Union
européenne les propositions qui nous
sont soumises vont nous conduire à un
déficit mes chers amis déjà en 2012 le
budget présente un déficit de 16
milliards d'euros résultat des courses
on a failli sacrifier Erasmus et
pénaliser des milliers d'étudiants quel
est le sens de tout cela que les chefs
d'État nous obligent à faire du déficite
je peux vous assurer monsieur le
Président que nous ne marcherons pas
dans cette combine il y a des règles et
nous allons les faire respecter à
commencer par l'article 310 du traité
qui oblige à un équilibre budgétaire
dois-je rappeler que c'est cette même
course déficit qui a mené les
États-membres dans la situation
économique actuelle c'est tout de même
unro inroyable ce que les États-membres
nous proposent d'un côté il nous demande
de renforcer la gouvernance économique
avec le Sixpack le toutpac et une
demande d'empêcher la course au déficit
et de l'autre il voudrait nous faire
prendre les mauvaises habitudes on
voudrait nous faire avaler un budget
avec 960 milliards d'euros de crédit
d'engagement contre seulement environ
900 milliards d'euros de crédit de
paiement n'importe quel chef
d'entreprise vous dira qu'un tel écart
est suicidaire
et monsieur le Président surtout il
serait trop facile il ne faut pas vous
cacher derrière Monsieur David Cameron
vous êtes en face d'un choix entre deux
camps opposés et vous l'avez bien dit
quel choix vous voulez faire alors
choisissez la bonne option et ne
choisissez pas l'option d'Avid Cameron
pour il veut détricoter petit à petit
l'Union européenne soit vous choisissez
l'option du Parlement européen pour une
Union européenne capable de relever les
défis vous devez dire clairement les
choses à vos concitoyens monsieur le
Président je voudrais vous remercier
d'avoir fait ratifier par votre majorité
le traité budgétaire car c'est un bon
signal pour l'Europe mais j'aimerais
vous poser une autre question j'ai beau
cherché je ne vois pas où est passé
votre Pact de croissance de 120
milliards d'euros où sont ces milliards
monsieur le Président dites-le nous nous
sommes des
législateurs
nous sommes des législateurs et nous
sommes de bonne volonté mais nous
n'avons nous avons une responsabilité
vis-à-vis de nos citoyens nous sommes là
pour discuter et négocier mais sachez
qu'il y a des points sur lequels nous ne
transigerons pas le premier c'est la
flexibilité il faut donner une réelle
flexibilité au cadre financier entre les
lignes budgétaires et entre les années
c'est comme ça que nous arriverons à
gérer correctement notre budget dans un
contexte d'austérité et d'équilibre
budgétaire le deuxème point c'est les
ressources propres si à terme le budget
européen est financé directement cela
permettra de diminuer d'autant les
contributions des États-membres et
surtout cela mettra fin au système de
marchandage et de maquignonnage et
surtout aussi au système des fameux
cheèqus retours et le troisième point
c'est d'introduire une clause de
révision les chiffres actuels sont
limités à cause de la crise nous en
prenons acte et j'espère aussi et nous
espérons tous ici que d'ici 2 à 3 ans
nous nous trouverons dans une meilleure
situation on aura alors besoin d'un
nouveau budget et aussi d'une
harmonisation fiscale et sociale je sais
que certains craignent que le conseil de
jeudi vendredi soit un échec ce n'est
pas mon cas je connais même un très bon
moyen d'éviter un mauvais accord on
fonctionne pendant 2 3 ans avec des
budgets annuels comme vous l'avez dit on
fait le point on nous prépare les n
nouvelle perspective comme vous l'avez
dit cela ne nous pose aucun
problème chers chers collègues il ne
faut pas craindre ce passage au budget
annuel parce qu'en l'état actuel des
choses de toute façon il faudra qu'on
prenne des décisions courageuses il nous
manque 60 milliards au budget on renonce
à quoi au nom des 60 milliards à Erasmus
au fond social européen au programme de
recherche il faut qu'on nous dise la
vérité où on va trouver ces 60 milliards
monsieur le Président chers collègues
comportons-nous en homme d'État et non
en homme politique parce qu'un homme
d'État pense aux prochaines générations
et au chômage des jeunes nous assistons
à une Haos sans précédente des
populismes de droite comme de gauche il
est de notre responsabilité de rappeler
à nos concitoyens que l'Europe qui
protège c'est une réalité sans celle
nous aurions été frappé encore beaucoup
plus de durement par la crise et tous
les oiseaux de mauvais augur qui
annonçaient la fin de l'euro nous leur
avons donné tort monsieur le Président
aujourd'hui les États ne peuvent plus
tout l'Europe c'est notre chance c'est
notre force l'Europe c'est nos valeurs
et en plus des états elle protège nos
concitoyens ce n'est vraiment pas le
moment de détruire notre rempart et
notre image je vous remercie de votre
attention
je donne la parole au groupe des soci au
nom du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates à Monsieur
hanoboda monsieur le Président je
voudrais tout d'abordcier d'être là
parmi nous à Strasbourg à un moment où
la France assume d'important respabilité
au Mali vous avez prise une décision
courageuse en engageant des soldats
français et africains pour libérer un
pays de jou
djihadistes vous pouvez compter sur
notre soutien dans cette lutte contre
les terroristes mais nous avez besoin
d'une nouvelle alliance entre l'Europe
et l'Afrique pour combattre le
terrorisme ensemble le trafic de drogue
mais aussi la pauvreté et la
corruption vous avezt lu monsieur le
Président un moment où l'Europe traverse
une triple crise une crise économique
sociale et politique au cours de ces 8
mois vous avez déclenché les changements
en Europe et c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour l'Europe et ses citoyens Madame
Merkel n'est plus le commandant en chef
commandant de couple mercossi l'Europe a
besoin d'une relation francalement
équilibré ouverte au compromis et tourné
vers
l'avenir grâce à vous monsieur le
Président l'Europe
disposeformé d'un pacte croissance pour
corriger le mfit d'une austérité
budgétaire aveugle mais il faut
maintenant dunamisser ce pacte pour
réussir et créer plus d'emplois les
coûts de chômage sont énormes et
représent plus de 1 % des produits
intérieur BR vous avez monsieur le
Président Madame mer premier accord vers
la mise en place d'une union bancaire en
Europe nous devons on trouvé maintenant
un accord entre le Parlement et les
ministres des finances européennes dans
quelques semaines l'Europe sociale n'est
plus aux abonnés absents l'engagement
été pris de renforcer la dimension
sociale de la zone euro mais nous
demandons de mesures
concrètes ce sont des progrès tangibles
mais l'Europe est toujours en crise dans
ce Parlement les socialistes et
démocrates part début des mois afin
d'empcher l'économie européenne de
succomper à une overdose d'austérité ce
n'est pas notre vision de l'Europe mon
groupe a proposé il y a déjà 2 ans que
l'on déduit certains investissement du
calcul des déficit public avec une règle
d'or peine perdue la droite dans cette
enceinte s'y oppose
farougement aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président la zone euro entre dans un
2uxe année des récession les chôages
explosent
à la fin de cette année l'Europe
comptera 10 millions de Jain en plus par
rapport de
2008 nous ne voulons pas plus de cette
austérité qui pousseent nos peup peuple
dans le chômage et la pauvreté il faut
donner de l'oxygène à l'économie
européenne même les très libéral
authodoxes fond monétaire international
dirigé par Madame legarde a fait son m
culpa reconnaissance être trompé sur
l'impact politique don austérité mon
groupe des socialistes et démocrates
milite en faveur d'une consolidation
budgétaire raisonnable et supportable
pour le peuple pour reprendre une
formule du président mitaran il faut
donner du temps au temps l'Europe
monsieur le Président doit investir pour
retrouver le chemin de la croissance
elle regagnera en compétitivité en
innovant par des investissements dans la
recherche et le développement les
nouvelles technologies et l'envir
monsieur le Président dans 2 jours vous
participerez à une réunion cruciale pour
l'avenir de l'Europe
elle porte sur le budget de l'Union
européenne pour les 7 prochaines années
nous voulons un budget ambitieux
modernisé orienté vers la croissance et
l'emploat et c'est là monsieur le
Président que le couple franco-allemand
doit se manifester sonir et comme vous
avez dire faire d'économie oui affaiblir
l'économie européenne non c'est not vre
position donc comme groupe socialiste et
démocrate enfin nous devons pouruivre
les réformes pour stabiliser durablement
la zone ao sans fermer la porte au pays
qui veulent le rejoindre mais les
réformes économiques devront s'appuyer
aussi sur un Pact social solide je
citeraire exemple une garantie pour la
jeunesse sur laquelle votre
gouvernement déjà très engagé nous
sommes 100 % d'accord avec vous
euh le rôle pour la jeunesse un revenu
minimum dans l'Europe une relance du
dialogue social au niveau national
européenne votre gouvernement a déjà
impronté ses chemins en permettant un
accord historique entre les partenaires
sociaux la zoneo doit en être resté
attractif offrir les garanties
démocratiques nécessaires et les
parlements européen en associant avec
les parlements nationaux doit jouer
pleinement son rôle monsieur le
président nous venons de fêter les 50
ans de l'amité franco-allemande mais un
autre anniversaire ne peut nous laisser
unérant les 60 ans du premier traité
européenne la Communauté européenne de
charbon et de l'acier aujourd'hui
l'acier européenne est menacé des morts
notre sidologologie est la proie des
prédateurs venus d'ailleurs et monu de
promesses
maisongères certains dirig dirigeentss
estiment que l'industrie n'est plus un
secteur d'avenir ils se trompent
lourdement l'Europe sans industrie c'est
une Europe encore plus vulnérable dans
un monde
globalisé voilà euh les éléments de
stratégie globale et progressiste de
compétitivité ce qui ne voudrait pas
nuritquetir le navire il verrait bien ce
qu' en coûterait d'être livré seul au de
balance mondial pour nous
socio-démocrates l'Europe à la carte
n'est pas une option ce n'est pas notre
vision de l'Europe l'Europe n'est pas
qu'un simple grand marché tout pour vu
d'ambition politique depuis début la
construction européenne àestin l'union
politique union fait de solidarité entre
les peuples et nation une union fondée
sur les valeurs humanistes union qui
garantit l'égalité entre hommes et
femmes union porteuse de tolérance et de
justice et qui n'accepte aucune
discrimination fondée sur la
les sexes ou les origines et à ces
propos propos monsieur le Président je
me félicite que votre gouvernement
défend le mariage pour tous c'est aussi
notre
position monsieur le Président le
changement est en cours en France il est
aussi en cours en Europe il faut
poursuivre dans cette voie afin de
construire m temps une Europe
socialement plus juste plus solidaire et
plus plus forte dans la compétition
mondiale vô monsieur le Président est
crucial il ne faut pas céder à la vision
simple d'un marché simple que
monsieuraron c'est pas notre
vision la vision de Monsieur Camaron au
contraire au contraire vous devez dire
Madame Merkel monsieur le Président
Angela
Hel
t des hommes d'État avec une vision
européenne aide-moi à redonner vie au
rêv européens vous avez monsieur le
Président lancer votre campagne en
France en promettant de réenvter le rêve
français maintenant en qualité de
membres du Conseil européen vous pouvez
nous aider à rinventer le rêve européen
merci monsieur le
président
merci Monsieur sola au nom du groupe de
l'alliance des libéraux et démocrates je
donne la
par en fait monsieur l'a déjà fait mais
je vais quand même le répéter
permettez-moi d'abord de féliciter les
libéral qui est en vous si vous me le
permettez je ne veux pas créer trop de
problèm chez vos amis socialist
naturellement pour vous mais votre
combat en
effet pour le mariage pour tous est un
progrès une nouvelle liberté et le cœur
du combat que nous menons avec notre
groupe merci pour
ça il y a 60 ans comme vous le savez
jean-monet disait euh nous unissons des
hommes nous ne coalisons pas des états
et en fait monsieur le Président ça
reste vrai notre union n de sens qui
elle devient une une véritable
fédération
de peuples et de nations ce que Winston
Churchill appelait les États-Unis
d'Europe mais naturellement pour monie
et pour churcheld cette union n'était
qu'une un rêve lointain je dirais même
un mirage tandis que aujourd'hui elle
est devenue un devoir je dirais un
devoir vital pour la survie de l'Europe
parce que disonsle le monde
d'aujourd'hui ce n'est plus une planète
de presque 200 état
mais c'est devenu quelque chose de
différent un conglomérat de grandes et
puissantes fédérations d'Empire de
civilisation prenez par exemple la Chine
la Chine n'est pas une nation c'est une
civilisation l'Inde par exemple c'est
pas une nation c'est un continent avec
2000 ethnies avec 22 langues et avec au
moins qu grands religions et les
États-Unis sont le pays multiculturel
par excellence donc l'avenir de l'Europe
l'Europe n'a qu'un avenir si elle aussi
comme vous l'avez indiqué fait le saut
vers une grande fédération je dirais un
empire mais un empire du bon et la
civilisation européenne contrairement à
ceux qui ni en fait l'existence de
l'Europe n'est pas une chimère mais
c'est une réalité qu'on peut voir qu'on
peut ressentir de la Volga jusqu'à
l'océan Atlantique de plus soyons honnêt
envers les citoyens envers nos électeurs
comment résoudre la crise financière
comment résoudre la récession économique
le changement climatique ce sont tous
des dossiers qui demandent une action
commune une approche globale qui dépasse
les limites de la souverainité nationale
et ce qu'il faut dire aujourd'hui aux
citoyens que c'est au niveau européen
qu'il faut regagner cette souverainité
qu'il faut défendre nos intérêts parce
que c'est la seul niveau où cette
souverainité dans le monde demain peut
être exercé et je crois monsieur le
Président que de tous les pays État
membbrre de l'Union européenne c'est la
France peut-être avec l'Angleterre qui
avait déjà compris il y a des siècles
qu'une unification de son territoire de
son économie de sa gestion publique
pourrait être bénéfique pour les
habitants et donc je dirais que la
France a la vocation je dirais même le
devoir de pousser maintenant cela cette
unification au niveau de notre continent
la France est plus que quiconque que
comme les paroisses ont disparu dans le
concert des Nation du 19e les nations ne
seront plus dominantes dans le 21e
siècle de demain et donc dans ce cadre
là il y a une bataille qui va se
dérouler vendredi prochain mais je me
demande après les discours de Joseph
Dole qu'est-ce que vous allez encore
discuter mais en tout état de cause les
futures finan l'Union il ne faut pas
nier naturellement les difficultés
financières actuelles mais est-ce que
vous pouvez peut-être est-ce que c'est
si difficile monsieur le Président de
faire comprendre à vos collègues qu'en
tant d'austérité mieux vaut mettre en
commun les rares ressources plutôt que
de renationaliser les politiques
européennes donnons quelques exemples
défense diplomatie recherche innovation
ce sont des dizaines de milliards qui
peuvent être épargnés si on collabore
ensemble dans le cadre d'un budget
européen renforcé comme il y a aussi des
millions à épargner si on veut entamer
le dialogue sur la question du siège de
nos
institution
malheureusement malheureusement c'est
l'inverse qui se produit pour le moment
il y a un strabisme politique qui
gouverne l'Europe soyons honnête pire
c'est une véritable j'utilise le mot
escroquerie budgétaire qui se prépare
vendredi prochain en mettant en effet
collègues les engagements à quel niveau
au niveau souhaité par les pays de
cohésion et on met alors les paiements
au niveau souhaité par les pays
contributeurs résultat du courses un
déficit de 60 milliards d'euros en plus
des 16 milliards qu'on a déjà maintenant
76 milliards de déficit dans les pardon
76 je m'excuse j'utilise le français de
la Belgique monsieur comte bandit mais
ça ne change rien à ce déficite
naturellement ça reste le même et bien
je vous dis je vous dis c'est une énorme
problème c'est et c'est peut-être très
étrange que je vous le demande monsieur
le Président vous qui êtes socialiste
dites non s'il vous plaît dites NON et
disons NON ensemble non à un cadre
financier qui n'est pas sérieux et non à
un cadre financier qui n'est
certainement pas à la hauteur de nos
défis voilà le message qu'il faut donner
vendredi prochain et finalement je veux
quand même revenir sur la question du
Mali vous avez je crois et vous l'avez
entendu les applaudissements pris la
bonne décision il n'était pas concevable
qu'un régime djihadiste s'installe à
bamoko mais laissez-moi aussi parler
d'une autre
drame beaucoup plus grand pour le moment
c'est-à-dire la série 2 ans d'horreur
des dizaines de milliers de morts des
centaines de milliers de
réfugiés et je vous le dis chaque jour
perdu a aidé la rébellion démocratique
est un jour gagné par les insurgé
islamiste pour le moment parce queon le
sait Assad tombera j'en suis sûr mais ce
sont les djihadistes qui risquent de
gagner alors je vous en supplie et
peut-être on peut parler aussi de
savendredi plutôt que de ce budget qui
est
erroné il faut donner maintenant une
aide humanitaire massive il faut établir
une zone anti-aérienne au nord de la
Syrie et si on n' pas le courage de
faire cela donnons leur au moins les
armes antiaériennes pour qu'il puissent
se défendre euxmême dans cette situation
d'aujourd'hui monsieur le Président vous
avez été accueil en libérateur au
Mali j'espère que ensemble avec vos
collègues européens vous pouvez aussi
devenir les héros en Syrie
merciur ver je donne la parole à
Monsieur con Bendit monsur le Président
Monsieur le Président François je t'ai
compris le changement c'est maintenant
alors allons-y tout droit chiche et
banco et ne nous raconte pas d'histoire
entre nous même s'il y a beaucoup de
spectateurs deux choses tu as parlé des
valeurs des valeurs européennes il faut
avoir
l'intelligence de dire aussi
que pendant des années l'Europe quand
elle pactait avec les dictateurs au sud
de la Méditerranée ne défendaient pas
ces valeurs et que ces valeurs quand ces
peuples se sont révoltés ont été des
valeurs universelles et que nous avons
partagé avec ces peuples donc il est
important il est important aussi de dire
qu'il y a un équilibre difficile à
trouver en politique entre les valeurs
partagées et nos intérêts et que des
fois quand on soutient l'Arabie Saoudite
et je ne sais quelle autre force du mal
occidental et bien c'est au nom de nos
intérêts contre nos valeurs que nous
devons peut-être Laurent agir comme ça
mais disons-le que c'est une
contradiction des fois difficiles à
gérer et puis alors quand on parle
maintenant de l'Europe de l'avenir
parlons non seulement du budget mais il
y a un problème fondamental au Conseil
entre le conseil et ce Parlement c'est
quelle est l'idée ou la compréhension de
ce qu'est la valeur ajoutée du budget
européen la bêtise la plus grande est de
dire puisque nous sommes obligés de
faire des économies au niveau national
il faut faire des économies au niveau
européen c'est le contraire qui est vrai
le babas de l'histoire c'est parce que
il y a récession dans les États-membres
il faut un budget capable de relancer et
Joseph a raison Joseph Dole quand il dit
dit où est pas où sont passés les 120
milliards c'est pas de ta faute il faut
le demander que tu demandes ça à Madame
Merkel il faut que tu demande ça à
Monsieur chobleu c'est pas lui qui est
le chef du budget allemand ça aussi tu
dois le dire je dis ça pourquoi je dis
ça pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui les
citoyens européens ne la voient pas
cette relance au contraire quand on voit
la crise de la sidérurgie quand on voit
la crise de l'automobile et bien les
États nations la France comme
l'Allemagne croit pouvoir s'en sortir
seule ce n'est pas vrai on ne sauvera
pas l'automobile européenne on ne
sauvera pas la sidurgie européenne pays
par pays lançons vraiment maintenant un
défi lançons un défi de la mobilité du
redéploiement industriel en Europe par
exemple faisons EADS du tramoou
repensons la mobilité dans nos villes et
ce sera aussi un facteur d'exportation
comme Airbus est un facteur
d'exportation
donc quand tu dis quand tu dis il faut
de la lucidité il faut de la
détermination moi je R et de la
responsabilité je rajoute il faut de
l'imagination sinon on tourne en rond et
on fait rien de nouveau si c'est avec
les idées d'hier qu'on veut construire
le monde de demain et ben avec les idées
d'hier on a construit les contradictions
du monde d'aujourd'hui donc des fois il
faut les laisser les idées du passé
derrière nous pour retrouver des pour le
monde de demain et par exemple tu as
parlé de la pâac tu as parlé de la pâac
et n ne racontons pas d'histoire le
Rabet anglais le Rabet français c'est la
pâqu et aujourd'hui quand tu as parlé de
la pâac tu n'as parlé que de
l'argroalimentaire non la politique
agricole commune doit être au service de
tous les agriculteurs européens et non
pas d'une minorité de
l'agroalimentaire c'est ça qu'il faut
dire et sait quand on sait que 80 % de
l'argent de la PAC est réparti sur 20 %
des agriculteur je n'appelle pas ça de
la solidarité quand je sais que aussi
bien la France que l'Angleterre que
l'Allemagne s'oppose au plafonnement des
dépenses par exploitation si l'on
plafonnait les exploitation à 100000 €
et pour savoir les chiffres parce qu'on
nous dit mais ils sont complètement fous
il faut dire
que ceux qui qui ont plus de 300000 €
c'est 160 exploitations en France et
1200 en Europe plus de 100000 € c'est
5000 exploitations en France et 10000
exploitations en Europe pour des
millions d'agriculteur plafonnons
redistribuons pour tout le monde contre
les gros l'agroalimentaire peut se
défendre lui-même il a pas besoin du
budget européen et puis pour finir sur
Mali tu as eu raison mais il faut aller
jusqu'au bout maintenant il faut et
l'Europe doit jouer un gros rôle la
réconciliation c'est aussi la
réconciliation difficile c'est pas
facile avec les toirèges c'est aussi la
réation à l'intérieur du Mali et aussi
il faut dire que le problème du Mali
c'est parce que des pays qui ne sont pas
tout à fait démocratiques comme
l'Algérie par exemple n'ont pas jouer
leur rôle dans la région au contraire
ils jouent avec le feu en attaquant les
terroristes et en le soutenant d'un
autre côté donc dire la vérité aller
jusqu'au bout des choses c'est aussi au
niveau international et là je suis
d'accord c'est pas la France qui le peut
c'est l'Europe mais c'est une autre
histoire un autre compte de fait parce
qu'il nous faudrait une représentante
aux Affaires étrangères qui soit digne
de ce poste c'est pas tout à fait le cas
en ce moment c'est un autre problème
c'est un autre problème mais je dis si
tu veux vraiment faire une Europe
énergie faire une Europe de l'énergie
renouvelable faire une Europe qui en
2030 quand la France fera ça aura des
objectifs contraignants sur les
renouvelables et bien tous les
écologistes d'Europe diront François il
est avec nous et nous sommes avec lui
merci
au nom du groupe des conservateurs je
donne la parole à Monsieur
kalanan monsieur le
Président je voudrais comme les autres
dirigeants vous rendre hommage pour
l'opération en cours au Mali vos troupes
avec le soutien de forces d'autres
États-membres du
Royaume-Uni travaille pour garantir
notre sécurité je pense que nous sommes
tous d'accord pour vous féliciter sur ce
point monsieur le président
merci également pour ce débat ici à
Strasbourg aujourd'hui c'est une ville
très accueillante
magnifique une ville qu'il faudrait au
moins visiter une fois dans sa vie mais
peut-être pas une fois tous les
mois vous vous dites de
proeopéen mais si vous l'étiez
véritablement vous changeriez le traité
pour faire en sorte que ce Parlement
décide enfin de son
siège une grande majorité des députés de
différentes nationalités de tous les
groupes politiques y compris certains
députés français sont pour cette réforme
j'espère que vous allez la soutenir et
désolé aucun autre leader de parti
politique n'a eu le courage de le
mentionner monsieur le Président je ne
veux pas me concentrer uniquement sur la
question du sierge de Strasbourg je
voudrais vous faire passer un message
très simple merci merci pour avoir
démontré brillamment au reste de
l'Europe ce que fait un gouvernement
socialiste dans la pratique une fois que
vous êtes élu et bien vous êtes frappé
par la réalité politique économique et
donc vous devez en venir à des coupe
budgétaire alors j'espère que maintenant
du côté des autres socialistes qui font
campagne en Europe on se rend compte de
ce qui se passe quand on est élu
véritablement vous
savez dans mon pays quand les
socialistes ont été au pouvoir et qu'ils
sont partis ils ont laissé une petite
note au trésor en disant voilà désolé il
n'y a plus d'argent dans les caises de
l'État et d'ailleurs votre propre
ministre a admis que la banque était en
banquecûte et alors que se passe-t-il la
situation n'est pas meilleure dans
d'autres pays européen mais depuis que
vous êtes arrivé au pouvoir on a compris
combien un gouvernement socialiste
pouvait faire de mal à un pays aussi
talentueux que la
France alors nous avons eu des
gouvernements socialistes en Espagne en
Grèce au Portugal et nous savons très
bien ce qui s'est passé ce sont les
partis conservateurs de centre droit qui
sont là pour balayer pour remédier aux
erreurs de ces gouvernements socialistes
monsieur le
Président vous nous avez démontré ce qui
est l'avenir socialiste si on augmente
les taxes de 75 % si on passe à l'âge de
la retraite à 60 ans et si on a des
semaines de travail de 35 he oui
évidemment quand c'est la campagne
électorale c'est très attraayant mais
ensuite on se rend compte de ce que cela
représente en terme de compétitivité
Ronald Reagan disait ce qui suit si ça
bouge vous la posez si ça continue à
bouger vous réglementez et si ça arrête
de bouger vous subsidez alors c'est-être
une blague dans sa bouche mais
malheureusement certains ici considèrent
qu'il y a là un
manifeste si l'Europe veut s' s'tirer il
faut changer de
cap le marché unique pour les
socialistes veut dire des règles
du travail équitable ou encore une
imposition unique mais pour moi marché
unique cela veut dire un forum libre où
nous pouvons être concurrentiel les uns
vis-à-vis des autres et donc vis-àvis du
reste du monde j'insiste beaucoup sur ce
point parce que vous l'aurez compris
d'ailleurs dans votre discours ici dans
cette assemblée on dirait que Cameron
aurait en quelque sorte mentionner cette
cet avantage concurrentiel qui n'est pas
J
dans son discours d'il a de semaines
mais que veut dire marché unique et bien
cela veut dire que dans certains pays
vous avez des taxes qui sont inférieurs
comme en Irlande vous avez d'autres pays
où les règles du travail sont
différentes au Royaume-Uni et puis vous
avez d'autres éléments qui ne sont plus
les mêmes en Allemagne et ailleurs mais
de toute façon l'important c'est d'être
membre d'un marché unique et de d'être
en concurrence les uns avec les autres
après ce discours de David cabron votre
ministre des Affaires étrangères avait
dit que cette
approche revenait à vouloir participer
jouer dans une équipe de foot et jouer
demander à jouer au rugby après alors je
pense que effectivement il faut bien se
rendre compte de cette comparaison parce
que vous savez quand vous êtes sur un
terrain de football vous devez vous
rendre compte que c'est justement sur ce
même terrain que l'on a inventé le
rugby
maintenant nous savons que nous avons un
jeu qui est suivi par des millions de
personnes bon peut-être que ce n'est
plus vraiment le cas suite au match de
dimanche c'est peut-être en Italie que
l'on suis beaucoup plus le moi j'aime
bien le football j'aime bien le
Manchester
United oui attendez
monsieur nous avons engagé C nouveaux
joueurs français
au Manchester United alors je ne sais
pas c'est peut-être parce que vous avez
augmenté l'imposition à 75 % que ces
joueurs sont enthousiastes de quitter la
France en quel s je peux vous dire merci
beaucoup monsieur le
Président c'est unete pour la France
mais c'est un pour l'équipe de Newcastle
alors monsieur le
Président les quelques mois de votre
présidence ont démontré que le
socialisme pas l'avenir de l'
mer au nom du Group je donne la parole à
Monsieur
de
Monsieur monsieur le Président de la
République mes chers
collègues je demande de bien
vouloir
s'exprimer la
minorité dans cette enceinte qui
peut-être représente sans doute
représentera demain si ce n pas le cas
auour'hi l'immense majorité des peuples
à l'extérieur de cette enceinte monsieur
le
Président vous avez reçu les
félicitations chaleureuses de Monsieur
Baroso la Commission de
Bruxelles cela vous a satisfait
cela
m'inquiète vous avez eu un mot dans
votre propos qui est juste vous craignez
la
défiance des peuples européens peut-être
ce mot vous -il inspiré par votre
voisin qui a voté non en 2005 lors de la
dernière consultation
référendaire pour le
reste le compte de fait pour reprendre
une expression utilisée il y a un
instant continue
monsieur le Président je voudrais vous
dire
solennellement et de façon respectueuse
et
cordiale votre
rêve votre rêve de la fusion des nations
européennne par
l'intégration le rêve des élites
postnationales est un rêve qui s'est
évanoui dans le cœur des peuples
il s'est
désintégré parce que il était
tramé dans un tissu de
mensonge le mensonge de
Schengen qui devait nous apporter la
sécurité en abattant les frontières
internes le mensonge d'une Europe sans
protection douinière qui devait nous
apporter la
prospérité courant des
échanges
la fin de notre industrie est là vous le
savez et Monsieur Montebourg le déplore
tous les
jours et puis aussi l'euro qui devait
nous
apporter la
croissance et puis le pouvoir d'une
oligarchie à Bruxelles qui devait
finalement
rencontrer la confiance des
peuples aujourd'hui les peuples
s'éloignent ils s'éloignent parce que
partout c'est l'austérité
l'appauvrissement le marasme et le
sentiment d'un pouvoir de plus en plus
lointain alors on ne résout pas un
problème monsieur le Président avec les
mode de penser qu' l'ont
engendré
aujourd'hui ce que nous attendons de
vous c'est que vous prononciez un mot
tabou dans cette enceinte un mot tabou
dans le milieu confiné où se rencontent
les banquiers et les marchés les milieux
d'affaires et les grands profiteurs de
la mondialisation sauvage c'est le mot
référendum pour que les peuples puisse
exprimer leur aspiration profonde on a
besoin de Racine on a besoin de
frontières on a besoin de protection on
a besoin d'un univers d'un univers
juridique stable on a besoin de ne pas
perturber le droit de la filiation on a
besoin que vous protéger nos
attachements vitaux monsieur le
Président vous avez évoqué François
mitteran nous appartenons t les deux à
la génération qui a vu avec
bonheur tomber le mur de Berlin prenez
garde monsieur le Président ne marchez
pas trop sous le mur de mastrich il
pourrait s'effondrer sur
vous nom de la Gauche Unitaire je donne
la parole à
mamesieurce que vous pourez vous calmer
s'il vous plaît vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président
Hollande bienvenue au Parlement européen
bienvenu au Parlement
européen et je pense
qu'effectivement les discours sont
parfois importants surtout lorsqu'ils
s'inscrivent en faux par rapport au
discours d'autres chefs de
gouvernement vous avez et par votre
élection suscité de nombreux espoirs pas
seulement en France mais dans toute
l'Union européenne vous avez insisté
sur la crise bancaire le sauvetage des
banques les Produits Intérieurs Bruts
ont augmenté sans que grâce à ce
sauvetage des banques pour les profits
financiers sans que malheureusement le
niveau de vie des populations lui
augmenté dans les mêmes
proportions dans votre discours vous
vous êtes attaqué à la doctrine de
l'austérité vous avez espéré une
nouvelle lutte et en particulier un
renouvellement de la politique sociale
européenne vous nous avez dit qu'il
était important de réorienter la
politique européenne vous n'êtes pas
tout seul monsieur le Président de
nombreuses forces politique vous
soutiennent dans ce sens de nombreux
économistes également ont présenté les
mêmes arguments mais la question qui se
aujourd'hui est de savoir où nous en
sommes est-ce que nous sommes vraiment
capables d'éliminer les causes de la
crise la réponse malheureusement est non
la crise de la dette ne peut-être
surmontée que si nous sommes capables de
sortir de la crise mondiale de la crise
du capitalisme mondial si nous sommes
capables de sortir de cette crise
financière et économique de sortir
également de la crise provoqué par les
changements climatiques d'une façon
générale et ça nous en sommes très très
loin les marchés financier recommence à
spéculer sans aucune entrave la
spéculation immobilière reprend de plus
B dans plusieurs États-membres 120
milliards pour la croissance voilà ce
qui nous avait été promis mais de quelle
croissance s'agit-il s'il vous plaît
quels investissements quels crédits
quels fonds seront utilisés les dépenses
publiques n'arrêtent pas d'être renié
d'être réduites les propriétés publi les
biens publics sont bradés la santé
l'éducation toutes les dépenses en
faveur de l'environnement des services
publics disparaissent fond comme neige
au soleil et tout cela c'est la
politique de croissance que vous nous
promettez l'austérité et la restriction
salariale c'est un poison nous avons
besoin de discipline financière je le
convient mais lorsqu'il s'agit de
déficit à hauteur de milliards et de
milliards dans plusieurs États-membres
la politique de cohésion de l'Union
européenne doit-elle être la seule à en
supporter les conséquences nous nous N
sont en faveur de cette politique de la
cohésion alors il faut également lutter
contre la conditionnalité
macro-économique parce que cohésion et
conditionnalités ne vont pas de paire il
y a le centre de l'Union européenne mais
il y a également sa périphérie il ne
faut pas créer de clivage il ne s'agit
pas d'accepter le moindre compromis dans
ce domaine vendredi n'accepte aucun
compromis ces objectifs doivent être au
cœur de votre démarche et l'Union
européenne va échouer si ces programmes
de cohésion dispar si ces objectifs sont
abandonnés le chômage des jeunes on en a
beaucoup
parlé mais comment financer cette
garantie prévue pour les jeunes il
s'agit de créer des emplois avec une
justification une justice
sociale il ne s'agit pas de créer de
nouveaux emplois précaires pour les
jeunes nous avons besoin d'une
initiative européenne ambitieuse pour
garantir l'existance de notre jeunesse
encore un mot dernier mot à propos du
Mali à la différence de beaucoup
d'autres collègues ici dans cet
hémicycle nous considérons que
l'intervention militaire était une
mauvaise solution les les conséquences à
moyen terme et à long terme ne sont pas
prévisibles et qui en souffre au premier
chef les populations locales l'Union
Européenne a une responsabilité
vis-à-vis du Mali pas seulement à cause
de nos capacités d'exportation de nos
institutions
oc Occident qui n'ont pas été à la
hauteur
mais parce que nous devons répondre à la
population du Mali qui se tourne vers
nous la démocratie le respect de
l'environnement voilà ce qu'il nous
demande l'intervention militaire
maintenant qu'elle a eu lieu doit servir
d'occasion pour entendre ces
protestations ces revendication des
populations du Mali revendication de
justice deection environnement de
conditions de vie décente et de respect
de la nature voilà ce qui s'impose pour
la France pour l'Union européenne et si
c'est votre démarche nous serons à vos
côtés merci
madameimer au nom des non inscrits je
donne la parole à Madame Le Pen j'ai
écouté votre intervention monsieur le
Président celle de Monsieur do de
Monsieur verochad de Monsieur Svoboda je
constate que les louanges adressé les
uns aux autres demeure cette artifice
déjà usé du temps où votre prédécesseur
Nicolas Sarkozi était venu ici je me
souviens d'ailleurs qu'il s'était
adressé aux eurosceptique aux
eurocritiques que nous sommes en
annonçant notre disparition dans un
éclat de rire généralisé de ce Parlement
aujourd'hui force de constater que
l'hilarité flanquée des discours
enflammés sur l'avenir radieux de cette
union européenne a fait place au rictus
monsieur le Président à l'heure où votre
Ministre de l'économie vient enfin de
reconnaître que l'euro eff fort
peut-être d'ailleurs trop fort a-t-il
dit au moment où la monnaie unique
évolue au-dessus de 1 dollar 35 ce qui
pénalise durablement nos exportations
hors zone euro et plomb à l'intérieur de
la zone notre compétitivité par rapport
à l'Allemagne alors que la balance
commerciale de la France est en déficit
avec un record annuel de 70 milliards
d'euros alors que nos finances publiques
sont gravement surendetté ce qui menace
la solvabilité de la France plus de 1800
milliards d'euros de dett et près de
1500 milliards
d'intérêts déjà versés depuis
1973 alors que nous sommes à la feille
d'un chômage endémique il est plus que
TS de s'apercevoir que vous vous êtes
trompé de chemin que pour suivre dans
votre politique socio-économique
semblable d'ailleurs à celle de vos
prédécesseurs c'est faire le jeu
exclusif des puissances d'argent et
d'une Union européenne quasi
totalitaireune Europe de Bruxelles et de
Berlin sous l'emprise des
banstes des banster de Goldman sax dont
le seul objectif est la rentabilité
financière à court terme oui vous les
défendez monsieur conbendit ça ne
m'étonne pas de vous cette rentabilité
finan à court terme qui passe par la
déflation salariale puisque Goldman sax
demande une baisse de 30 % des salaires
avec pour conséquence et vous le savez
un véritable saccage social pourtant une
dévaluation externe s'imposerait pour la
compétitivité selon une étude de l'INC
une dépréciation de 20 % de l'euro
pourrait entraîner une hausse immédiate
d'environ 3 % du PIB réel cette
dévaluation
ne réglerait pas le problème de fond
bien sûr parce que celui-ci reste
l'existence d'une monnaie unique pour
tant de pays si différents mais elle
donnerait allez un petit bol d'air pur
un petit bol d'air
provisoire cette monnaie unique qu'il
faudra bien accepter de déconstruire
ensemble avant qu'elle ne le fasse
d'elle-même dans la surchauffe et la
panique des salles de marché
oui je parle des Européens mais et en
tant queeuro réaliste car les peuples
que vous êtes tous censés écouter et
servir se détourneent chaque jour un peu
plus de votre projet fédéraliste forcené
il se détournent parce que vous ne
montrez aucun signe allant dans le sens
notamment de leur
protection parce que vous vous refusez à
admettre vos erreurs et à changer
radicalement de chemin pire l'Europe de
la paix monsieur con Bendit devient
menaçante voire haineuse
ttoi Budapest aujourd'hui à Athènes
demain à Londres dès que les peuples
montrent des signes de résistance à vos
dictate mondialiste la réponse des
institutions européennes est celle
d'ailleurs que vient de démontrer
monsieur con Bendit le mépris
l'arrogance la menace et
l'insulte et
bien bien vous ne pourrez plus très
longtemps vous en sortir en capurant les
opposants que nous sommes à ce modèle
dans ces conditions monsieur le
Président quand au nom de la France et
d'e are Europe déciderez-vous enfin à
tourner le dos à ce modèle économique
ultralibéral et mondialiste qui détruit
depuis plus de 20 ans les
lementp votre temps parol merci
beaucoup
bien voilà qui est
fait je passe la parole à Monsieur
Holland président de la
République
bien je savais que en venant ici devant
le Parlement
européen ce serait un moment utile pour
préparer les échéances qui
arrivent et vraiment je vais vous
confirmer que je ne regrette pas m'a
venu ce matin non pas pour retrouver des
partenaires de la vie politique
française que j'avais plus l'occasion de
rencontrer depuis quelques mois mais
pour
entendre différents
groupes me demander de faire au Conseil
européen ce qui devrait être leur
responsabilité auprès des chefs d'État
et de
gouvernement qui leur sont proches
mais je dois dire que je pars avec dans
mes bagages tous les arguments
possibles pour avoir un
compromis avec un niveau élevé
d'exigence c'est vrai
que je suis
conscient que ce qui est aujourd'hui sur
la
table ne peut pas satisfaire une
majorité du Parlement
européen je dir donc à mes collègues
chefs d'État et de
gouvernement j'ai entendu le Parlement
européen dans sa
diversité souhaiter qu'il y ait un
niveau correct de
dépens et qu'il y ait des ressources qui
soi revu pour que nous puissions
envisager l'avenir avec
confiance je ne doute pas que le
président de la Commission européenne
fera rapport également de ses
interventions
parce que parfois à la table je ne vais
rien révéler ici du Conseil européen
j'entends un certain nombre dire mais
nous ferons notre affaire des groupes
parlementaires du Parlement
européen je veux croire que ce ne sera
pas le cas cette fois-ci donc que
devons-nous chercher
ensemble je l'ai dit d'abord éviter que
les coupes budgétaires finissent par
mettre en cause la croissance et je me
sens comptable du plan qui a
été adopté au mois de juin dernier et
Monsieur Joseph Dole me disait mais où
sont passés les 120 milliards d'euros et
bien ils devront pour une part être dans
le cadre financier européen ils sont
déjà dans la Banque européenne
d'investissement dont le capital a été
reconstitué à hauteur de 10 milliards
dans les obligations de projet mais ils
seront nécessairement ces crédits là
dans les fonds structurels ceux qui
n'ont pas été dépensés mais ceux qui ont
vocation à lêre dans le cadre financier
européen de la même
manière je ne peux pas défendre un
principe de solidarité en même temps
qu'un principe de croissance et
constater que certains pays continuent
d'exiger des chèqus et des rabaiss alors
même que ils nous disent mais vous vous
aurez la France
un avantage si on réduit les dépenses de
la
politique commune notamment de cohésion
parce que ça vous fera autant de moins
pour la contribution nette de votre pays
je n'accepte pas ce raisonnement je
considère que la France doit participer
pleinement au budget européen recevoir
ce qu'elle peut espérer mais ne pas
elle-même revendiquer un chè ou un Rabet
parce que ça voudrait dire que les
thèses de Madame satcher ont fini par
prévaloir ou chaque viendrait demander
le juste retour de sa
contribution mais je veux néanmoins
chercher le compromis car il serait pas
responsable de ma part comme chef d'état
d'un grand pays européen de souhaiter
l'échec je dois le chercher cet accord
et vous m'aiderez à le
trouver parce que si nous pensons qu'il
y a nécessité de préserver les
politiques communes je vais revenir sur
la politique agricole et de préserver
aussi les politiques de croissance nous
pouvons avoir un chiffre de 960
milliards d'euros d'engagement mais j'ai
bien compris que il y avait comme une
subtilité de distinguer engagement et
paiement et ça a été très bien démontré
par Monsieur verofstad en faisant en
sorte que nous pourrions promettre et ne
pas tenir mais nous ne pouvons pas
accepter qu'il puisse y avoir un déficit
chaque année du budget européen et
qu'ensuite ce serait vers les
états-membes qu'il faudrait se retourner
pour combler le trou qui serait ici
constaté au niveau européen
enfin de quoi parle-t-on avec le cadre
financier et le budget européen 1 % 1 %
de la richesse européenne et nous
serions en train de nous poser la
question de savoir si
un peu plus viendrait déséquilibrer
l'ensemble des budgets nationaux et bien
non nous pouvons faire en sorte que le
budget européen reste un budget de
croissance et c'est d'autant plus
nécessaire ça a été rappelé que nous
avons à mettre de l'ordre dans nos
finances publiques et donc nous avons à
faire nous-même des réductions parfois
difficiles de crédit et donc nous avons
besoin d'un soutien européen et puisque
l'on évoque un certain nombre de
références venant d'autres époques ou
d'autres continents à un moment il faut
bien que ce qui existe au niveau fédéral
au niveau en tout cas ici européen
puisse permettre de
contrebalancer ce que nous faisons au
niveau
national
sur les priorités qu' évoqué monsieur
Swoboda il a raison de dire qu'il y a 60
ans nous avons été capable d'inventer la
Communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier que sûrement il y a
aujourd'hui toujours dans ces secteurs
là des restructurations à opérer mais
également des industries à préserver je
crois à la sidérurgie
européenne mais nous avons aussi Daniel
conbit nous appelit à être dans
l'imagination de ce point de vue il y a
quand même une cohérence chez lui de la
mettre au
pouvoir mais est-ce que nous ne
pourrions pas faire aujourd'hui et pour
les 50 prochaines années la Communauté
européenne de l'énergie où nous
mettrions en place les instruments pour
l'efficacité énergétique le
développement du renouvelable et la
moindre dépendance par au énergies
fossil et bien engageons ces politiques
mais ça suppose qu'il y ait aussi des
crédits qui soit maintenu dans le cadre
financier européen et c'est vrai que la
facilité consiste à aller chercher les
dépenses d'avenir pour préserver un
certain nombre de dépenses du présent ou
du passé je veux parler de la politique
agricole non pas parce que je serai le
représentant de la France et forcément
attaché simplement à ces crédits là je
ne peux pas laisser penser que la France
ne serait pas favorable à un
plafonnement des aides agricoles nous y
sommes favorables de la même manière je
suis conscient qu'aujourd'hui ce sont
les productions animales qu'il convient
de favoriser par rapport simplement aux
productions végétal et qu'il y a une
vraie crise de l'élevage en Europe
contte tenu du coût des matières
premières et notamment du cours des
céréales et enfin je suis prêt à
accepter une diminution des aides
directes mais avoir aussi un deuxième
pilier le développement rural qui puisse
permettre à toutes les agricultures
d'être ainsi soutenu par l'Union
européenne et je l'ai bien dit avec des
règles sur le respect de l'environnement
parce que je connais certains pays qui
maintenant veulent remettre en cause le
verdissement de la politique agricole
alors que cet été ça a été un progrès
pour à la fois l'agriculture et pour
l'Union européenne de la même façon je
suis favorable aux politiques de
cohésion pas simplement pour satisfaire
les demandes des pays qui sont les plus
concernés mais parce que nous avons
besoin d'avoir cette solidarité et nous
avons besoin d'avoir des investissement
qui puisse tirer l'ensemble de
l'économie européenne voilà pourquoi je
je ferai en sorte
de défendre non pas le Parlement
européen mais l'idée simple que si nous
voulons un accord il doit être ensuite
adopté par le Parlement
européen et que il servirait à rien pour
plaire à celui-ci ou à celle-là de
trouver un compromis de jours durant une
nuit comprise pour ensuite nous
réveiller avec le refus du Parlement
européen alors essayons ensemble de
défendre la position qui nous paraîtra
la meilleur il y a effectivement un
paradoxe qui sera relevé c'est que ceux
qui sont les plus attaché à vouloir des
coupes dans le budget européen sont sont
ces pays qui ont le plus à perdre si on
revient à l'annualisation du budget
européen et je leur demande d'y
réfléchir parce qu'un certain nombre de
chèqus et de Rabet tomberont si nous
revenons à une procédure annuelle et il
y aura aussi sur un C nombre de dépenses
plus de dépenses avec le budget annuel
qu'il y en aurait avec un compromis sur
le cadre financier
européen je veux également vous
remercier pour le soutien que vous avez
apporté à l'intervention française au
Mali je pense
que nous ne pouvions pas prendre une
autre
décision ne pas prendre de décision
aurait abouti ce n'est pas une hypothèse
c'est une certitude à ce que les groupes
terroristes contrôlent l'ensemble du
Mali et contrôlant l'ensemble mal P sur
les pays de l'ensemble de l'Afrique de
l'Ouest évoquer
l'Algérie je veux ici dire combien
l'Algérie a souffert pendant des années
et des années du terrorisme et que s'il
y a un pays qui ici est la victime de la
barbarie c'est bien
l'Algérie et qu' a été
enc ces derniers jours avec cette prise
d'otage et que moi je n'ai pas
discuté de ce qui a été fait par les
Algériens sur leur territoire
pour frapper les terroristes qui
retenaient en otage 600
personnes alors nous aurons besoin de
l'Algérie dans cette région du monde
nous aurons besoin de l'Algérie pour
lutter contre le terrorisme nous aurons
besoin de l'Algérie pour favoriser une
politique
de développement nous aurons besoin de
l'Algérie pour le dialogue politique y
compris avec les
toirg sur le Mali madame je peux vous
dire une chose revenant de bamaco et de
tombouou les populations que j'ai vu et
qui ne se sont pas rassemblé parce qu'on
leur avait demandé de le faire et qui
ont acclamé non pas le président
français mais les soldats qui étaient
présents au Mali ces populations là
elles étaient libérées de la servitude
de l'oppression et de la barbarie et ce
qu'elle nous demandait c'est de rester
et ce que je leur ai répondu c'est que
nous resterons que
si les Africains eux-même en décide et
surtout nous resterons le temps
nécessaire parce que nous avons besoin
que ce soit les Africains qui assurent
leur propre sécurité mais une chose est
certaine et je vous ici le promets c'est
que si N nous le voulons tous nous avons
maintenant le devoir dans cette région
là d'être présent de donner non pas une
aide non pas des subsides non pas des
concours momentanés mais une orientation
de
développement et de soutien à une région
du monde qui est parmi les plus pauvres
de la planète mais une région du monde
qui contient aussi des richesses mais à
cet égard je vous le dis aussi la France
est intervenue au Mali au nom de la
communauté inter au nom de l'Europe non
pas pour défendre un intérêt il n'y a
pas de mine il n'y a pas de ressources
pétrolière au Mali il n a pas des
entreprises françaises dont je voudrais
assurer la
protection au Mali il n'y a aucun
intérêt que poursuit la France en
intervenant en revanche ce que nous
protégion ce sont les Maliens eux-mêmes
et c'est la possibilité d'un
développement
économique et s'il y a une
responsabilité maintenant pour l'Europe
c'est de considérer que nous avons à
développer ces régions et dire aussi un
mot sur le dialogue politique je suis
conscient on me le dit souvent le plus
dur reste à faire oui le plus dur c'est
d'assurer la stabilité la sécurité oui
le plus dur c'est de faire que la
démocratie puisse être rétablie oui le
plus dur c'est de faire que ce problème
toarec qui remonte à loin et qui n'a pas
été réglé puisse l'être à cette occasion
mais là ce plus la responsabilité seule
de la France c'est la responsabilité de
toute l'Europe et je sais grâce à votre
soutien aujourd'hui qu'il sera possible
de l'apporter
merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président ch collèg il y aura une
deuxième série de questions et là je
vous demanderai de respecter très
strictement votre temps de parole nous
avons beaucoup de
retard nous allons procéder par ordre
inverse raison pour laquelle Madame Le
Pen sera la première intervenante vous
déposer vous disposer de 2 minutes très
exactement euh monsieur le Président
j'ai vu qu'il était politiquement
correct de taper en ce moment sur la
Grande-Bretagne d'ailleurs vous l'avez
fait faut bien le dire à de multiples
reprises bon vous pour de bonnes ou de
mauvaises raisons la Grande-Bretagne
remet publiquement en cause le système
mais alors que pensez de ceux qui tuent
sournoisement le système parce que il
faut quand même voir la réalité en face
il existe des pays qui sont des
fondateur historique de l'Europe qui
font un véritable dumping social
intensif sans que personne en
l'occurrence ne les montre du doigt
est-ce que c'est cette Europe là que
vous souhaitez c'est en tout cas pas
celle que vous mettez en place au grand
dame d'ailleurs des travailleurs
français je pense permettez-moi plus
particulièrement à l'Allemagne dont les
employés de l'Agriculture et de
l'Agroalimentaire travaillent pour des
salaires horaires de 3 à 4 € de l'heure
la généralisation de ces pratiques dans
des filières qui ne sont pas couvertes
par les accords de branche confinent à
l'esclavage de la vie même des syndicats
allemands et menace directement dépend
entier de l'économie française ah c'est
sûr pendant qu'il se taille la part du
Lyon à l'export et bien nos éleveurs
beauvin porsin avicol nos maréchés nos
industriels de la transformation perdent
chaque jour des parts de marché y
compris bien entendu en France alors on
nous dit mais Madame Merkel envisage de
mettre un salaire minimum et bien elle
réfléchit lentement c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire puisque ce sujet évoqué il y
a plus d'un an n'a toujours pas fait
l'ombre d'un début de commencement de
bonne volonté de sa part et pour cause
car vous ne pouvez ignorer qu'une des
raisons de la puissance économique de
l'Allemagne est précisément ce dumping
social alors aurez-vous le même courage
de dénoncer ces pratiques et de dénoncer
ce dumping social de l'Allemagne que
vous avez pu exprimer un courage en
dénonçant comme tous les autres
d'ailleurs les réticences de Monsieur
Cameron face au fonctionnement du
systèmeaven
je passe la parole à Monsieur le yaric
pour l'AGU je vous en prie
Monsieur Merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président de la
République vous avez insisté à juste
titre sur la nécessité d'une Europe
solidaire et vous vous battez avec votre
gouvernement contre une violente
fracture qui qui mine à cause des
politiques d'austérité nos peuples c'est
l'augmentation incessante du nombre de
pauvres et on est en train de tenter de
supprimer les crédits aujourd'hui du
Fond européen au plus démunis alors
qu'on donne des milliards aux banques ne
croyez-vous pas nécessaire pardà le
Conseil européen de faire un appel aux
peuples européens pour maintenir ce
niveau d'aide alimentaire seconde
remarque dans chaque pays désormais est
appliqué l'austérité budgétaire et
salariale c'est aussi le cas chez nous
en France soi-disant au nom de la
compétitivité c'est une vie sans fin qui
broie le travail et les droits
démocratiques mais la surélévation de
l'euro dont vous avez parlé à l'instant
n'est jamais combattu comme un handicap
à la compétitivité alors qu'elle détruit
des emplois et des entreprises n'est-il
pas grand temps de tenter de changer le
rôle de la Banque centrale européenne et
de transformer le mécanisme européen de
stabilité en un fond pour le
développement social humain et
écologique avec l'activation d'un
nouveau crédit au lieu de la flexibilité
du travail la baisse des rémunérations
du travail et la destruction de nos
services publics enfin vous avez parlé à
l'instant du vous avez apporté une
réponse à une question de Monsieur D sur
le pacte de croissance qui m'a un peu
surpris parce que vous avez dit que vous
allez le recycler dans le prochain
budget comme cela veut-il dire que les
fonds annoncés étai virtuels merci
beaucoup
merci je passe la parole pour le groupe
monsieur
farrage monsieur le Président euh
Hollande je ne sais pas si vraiment vous
faites quelque chose pour réduire
l'euroscepticisme bon vous avez vous
avez pris des décisions en ce qui
concerne l'imposition et je vois l'écart
de compétitivité se creuser avec
l'Allemagne
et on voit d'ailleurs toute une série de
personnes qui quittent le territoire
et nous voyons d'ailleurs l'évolution de
l'euro et je pense qu'il l'écart se
croise creusant entre la France et
l'emne je sais pas comment vous allez
pouvoir rester dans la même union
économique alors la France est en
faillite a dit un de vos ministres et
vous vous permettez néanmême une
intervention militaire au Mali
parfait bon effectivement il est heureux
de voir le visage heureux épanoui des
Maliens vous nous dites nous avons agi
au nom de l'Union c'est une mission de
l'uro tonbler disait il y a quelques
jours que l'Union européenne ce n'est
pas cela c'est une question de pouvoir
je pense que ce qu'il a voulu dire c'est
que l'Union
européenne risque de plus en plus de se
lancer dans des guerres bon nous avons
vu la
au Mali les
libéraux sont d'accord et ça peut aller
plus loin les libéraux aujourd'hui nous
demandent de faire également quelque
chose en Syrie il n'y a pas de fin
l'Union devrait intervenir du de façon
militaire dans différents pays du monde
mais je ne sais pas si la bonne réponse
d'ailleurs au fondamentalisme islamique
et je ne suis pas convaincu quant à moi
mais je j'ai les plus graves
préoccupations nous allons nous lancer
dans des opération telles que Cell de
l'Afghanistan alors je ne veux pas qu à
moi que l'Union le Royaume-Uni fasse
partie de cette stratégie militaire et
je m'inscris en faux contrairement à ce
qu'on dit beaucoup de mes collègues
ici je vous remercie je passe la parole
à Monsieur kalanan de nouveau merci
monsieur le Président je pense que notre
discussion a été excellente aujourd'hui
je voudrais encore une fois vous
remercier d'avoir accepté ce débat avec
nous
vous n'étiez pas obligé de le faire en
tant que chef d'État et votre
prédécesseur ne l'avait jamais fait
alors je vous remercie pour
cela maintenant si vous voulez
poursuivre votre politique socialiste en
France et bien je vous souhaite bonne
chance bon travail bonne chance de
toutes les façons ça va pas marcher mais
bonne chance je voudrais simplement vous
demander quelque
chose les syndicalistes socialistes ne
doivent pas interférer avec le bon
fonctionnement du marché intérieur je
pense en particulier aux actions
récentes des pêcheurs français à
Boulogne qui ont empêché des bateaux
néerlandais et belges de débarquer leur
prise à Boulogne ils ont même vandalisé
détruit des bateaux néerlandais et et
belge la ligne d'ouvrecalis est
régulièrement bloquée par des
agriculteurs par des pêcheurs avec des
embouteillage épouvantable dans le
sud-est de l'Angleterre alors il
faudrait peut-être établir l'ordre dans
vos PS monsieur le Président et
permettre au pêcheurs de travailler
librement ne pas utiliser le marché
intérieur pour essayer d'harmoniser
l'ensemble de l'Europe à votre modèle
quant à ceux qui quittent les capitaux
qui quittent la France il ne quitte pas
l'Europe il quitte la France simplement
Président si on a bien écouté tout ce
qui a été dit ici on ne peut pas trouver
un compromis pour le budget Prut annuel
je crois que la proposition de Joseph do
mon camarade de groupe est la
c'est de dire que attendons 2014 faisons
2 ans de budget année par année et
trouvons ensemble ce qu'est l'intérêt
général européen la crise du budget
c'est la crise de la compréhension de ce
que serait l'intérêt général européen
donc la Communauté européenne de
l'génergie elle est sacrifiée en ce
moment dans ce budget par connecting
Europe et toutes les infrastructures des
énergie renouvelable vous pouvez prendre
des tas d'exemples où effectivement
aujourd'hui on tire tout au Rabet et et
on y'y arrivera pas Jacques Delor dit il
faut augmenter le budget européen de 20
% elmou Schmidt nous dit il faut que le
Parlement européen fasse un PCH donc moi
comme je suis devenu pacifiste je dis il
faut trouver un compromis entre le
Conseil et le Parlement et ce compromis
c'est aucun compromis aujourd'hui
rouvrons la discussion les débats et
après nous pourrons en 2014 après les
élections européennes avoir un budget
pluriannuel qui sera contrôlé mocrati
merci beaucoup monsieur très
bien Madame de saret a la parole
monsieur le Président nous savons les
difficultés qui touchent l'Europe et le
doute qui s'installe parfois à l'égard
de l'idée même européenne mais nous
savons aussi et c'est ma conviction que
la seule façon d'y répondre c'est
d'affirmer d'assumer la nécessité
historique d'une Europe plus unie et
plus forte ce que vous avez fait ce
matin et je pense que nous devons agir
dans deux directions si nous voulons
retrouver l'adhésion des peuples d'abord
et c'est évident il manque à l'Europe de
savoir décider et cette faiblesse elle
nourrit tous les doutes l'Europe se
réunit interminablement mais elle ne
tranche pas nous voulons une Europe qui
décide sur un budget conséquent àamasson
va en parler encore sur une ressource
propre sur une vraie politique
énergétique sur notre indépendance
industrielle sur les questions
monétaires vous l'avez dit de politique
étrangère ou de défense décider c'est le
cœur même de la politique monsieur le
Président vous venez de vivre
l'intervention au Mali vous avez vérifié
combien il a été crucial de pouvoir
trancher en quelques heures pour
défendre les valeurs que nous défendons
et que nous partageons tous ici il n'est
pas de crise où l'Europe soit en mesure
de décider en temps utile nous voulons
que cela change mais plus il y aura
d'Europe et plus cette Europe exigera
pour être légitime de devenir
authentiquement démocratique
il faut que les citoyens aent accès aux
dirigeants de leur union qu'il les
connaissent qu' les élisent directement
qu'il connaissent et qu'il valident les
orientations politiques que l'Europe met
en œuvre pour eux en leur nom voilà
monsieur le Président les convictions
sont les mienes voilà l'espoir qui est
le mien je vous remercie merci
Madame pour le groupe socialiste je
passe la parole à Madame
trotman merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais m'adresser au président de la
République ici je ne m'adresse pas à
François car c'est un plaisir et un
honneur de le faire au nom de mon groupe
dans cette période troublée que d'cun ou
d'cun s'interroge sur le devenir de
l'Union et c'est l'objet de notre débat
de ce matin ou même sur la raison d'être
de l'Union je voudrais rappeler ce à
quoi nous aspirons et ce à quoi aspirent
les Européens à plus de solidarité
solidarité des Européens à
l'international
vous avez pu entendre monsieur le
Président l'assentiment large de notre
assemblée s'agissant de l'intervention
au Mali mais parceque les Européens ne
peuvent pas sous-traiter les affaires
militaires à certains États-membres
seulement il faut mettre sur le métier
une authentique politique de sécurité et
de défense commune solidarité interne
aussi et surtout c'est le sens de votre
démarche de réorientation de l'Europe le
budget communautaire et par conséquent
les négociations sur le cadre financier
pluriannuel sont un test politique de
solidarité où se vérifie notre
crédibilité c'est-à-dire l'adéquation
entre les politiques votées et les
moyens de les réaliser ce débat a été
clairement posé par mes prédécesseurs
dans ce débat je voudrais dire au nom de
notre groupe que pour nous c'est non
aussi mais ce ne sera pas la politique
de la chaise vide vous l'avez dit nous
devons prendre la responsabilité la
lucidité de discuter les conditions dans
lesquelles nous pouvons avoir le budget
qui correspond aux politiques que nous
avons voté quand nous débattons des
perspectives financières nous devons
tracer des perspectives d'avenir pour la
jeunesse pour l'emploi et pour la
croissance c'est la raison d'être du
budget communautaire un budget
d'investissement et le fondement de la
mise en commun de nos ressources mais
qui ne peut plus se résumer au seul
contribution nationale nous avons besoin
de ressources propres comme les
transactions financières à laquelle la
France la taxe sur les transactions
financières à laquelle la France a
beaucoup contribuer et peut constituer
une première pierre de ses ressources il
s'agit pour tous d'orénavant de se doter
d'outils modernes pour penser notre
croissance et nous serions incapables
d'organiser la solidarité entre les
peuples d'Europe il faut ici parler du
Fond européen d'aide au plus démunis
dont l'avenir soulève de nombreuses
incompréhensions dans nos populations au
risque précisément d'y perdre notre
crédibilité la proposition de la
Commission doit être entendue la forme
juridique de notre action pour les plus
démunis ne dépendra pas ne dépendra que
pardon de notre volonté à mettre en
œuvre cette solidarité sans obérer les
autres politiques du Fond Social
Européen parallèlement nous devons
concevoir un plan européen
d'investissement pour créer de nouveaux
emplois et réaffecter une partie des
fonds structurels à des projets pour les
jeunes au-delà du Pacte pour la
croissance et l'emploi c'est le sens de
la garantie pour la jeunesse européenne
enfin et je conclurai nous devons
travailler em à la légitimité de tous
les parlements nationaux et européens
nous devons devenir des céciseurs de
l'examen annuel de croissance en respect
de la souverainé des parlements
nationaux et des progrès que notre
Parlement peut apporter à la
démocratie merci Madame
trman le dernier intervenant de ce débat
est Monsieur lamassour vous avez la
Paro mer monieur présidentieur président
de la
républ France est un pays normal mais ça
n'est pas un état ordinaire et dans
cette période d'incertitude l'Europe
attend deux choses d'elle d'abord
qu'elle soit exemplaire chez elle
qu'elle honore les engagements qu'elle a
pris qu'elle joue en harmonie dans le
concert européen elle en a accepté la
partition commune et l'Europe vous en
est reconnaissance mais cette partition
votre gouvernement l'exécute avec de
curieuses dissonances et là l'Europe
s'étonne quand la durée de la vie
s'allonge la France d'aujourd'hui
rajunit l'âge de la retraite entre 60 et
62 ans quand la fiscalité partout est
mise au service de la course aux emplois
aux capitaux aux talents la France donne
l'impression d'imposer toutes les formes
de réussite et même de punir ceux des
salariés qui osent travailler plus de 35
heur par
semaine ces
partenaires ces partenaires taillent
dans les dépenses administrative à la
hache la France y attaque avec une lime
à
ongle son gouvernement s'est engagé à ne
pas réduire d'un seul pour les 5
prochaines années le nombre de ces 5
millions de
fonctionnaires alors dans la deuxè
puissance économique de l'Union en ce
moment même la production s'arrête les
usines ferment le chômage augmente les
talents s'en vont et l'Europe
s'inquiète on attend aussi de la France
qu'elle éclaire la voix de l'Europe avec
ses partenaires les plus engagés vous
l'avez fait au Mali monsieur le
Président et le Parlement l'a salué cela
suppose une condition que la France
n'est écoutée que lorsqu'elle propose
une vision pour toute
l'Europe ce qu'il nous faut inventer
aujourd'hui ensemble c'est son modèle
c'est le modèle de solidarité de
l'Europe Catherine trotman l'a dit
votre chance c'est que c'est maintenant
qu'il nous faut décider du budget
européen jusqu'à la fin de la
décennie notre malheur c'est que à ce
jour de laave même du président Van
rompeuil autour de la table du Conseil
personne ne défend
l'Europe chacun ne parle que de lui vous
avez convaincu monsieur le Président de
la République le Parlement européen
quand vous avez plaidé pour un budget
élevé
il faut maintenant que vous convainquiez
le président de la République française
parce que certes le Royaume-Uni un droit
de V mais la France aussi un droit de V
et vous avez équé le président mit à
juste titre
madameait un droit de V SAF que le
président mit et h et sent responsable
de l'EUR ils ont accommoder la dame de
fer tout en doublant les fonds
régionaux sur les priorités européennes
vous l'avez dit nous en sommes d'accord
la valeur ajoutée d'un budget européen
c'est de permettre d'atteindre la masse
critique là où la mondialisation le rend
nécessaire d'un côté les grands
investissements d'avenir de l'autre
l'influence de l'Europe dans le monde
vous avez dit peser sur le destin du
monde alors trembleer concurrents d'Asie
ou d'Amérique trembleer terroristes de
tous les continent la proposition qui
est mise sur la table affecterait à la
recherche européenne
8 di milliè de
PIB et affecterait 7 100li à son action
extérieure et on nous dit je me trompe
en coulisse la franceemploie ardemment à
raboter encore ses chiffres pour
améliorer son retour
comptable au moins ce budget sera-t-il
équitable dans votre discours
d'investiture monsieur le Président à
Paris vous avez dit que la justice
l'équité serait le premier critère de
toute votre action
voilà une occasion de mettre ce principe
en pratique car le système actuel de
financement de l'Union est le plus
injuste qui soit 5 des pays les plus
riches paient relativement moins que les
10 pays les plus pauvres qui sont tous
des nouveaux membres le Parlement a
proposé une réforme d'ensemble fondée
sur de nouvelles ressources propres et
nous nous réjouissons de ce que vous
avez dit sur ce point la France se bat
elle en retient le principe mais juste
votre discours de ce matin elle se
battait surtout pour plafonner sa propre
contribution donc pour aggraver la
charge des pays pauvres du côté des
dépenses la potion magique qui est
concocté secrètement par les alchimistes
du Conseil européen aboutira à réduire
je dis bien à réduire pour les 7 années
qui viennent les fonds de cohésion
alloué par exemple à des pays comme la
Grèce le Portugal l'Espagne la Hongrie
jamais ces pays n'ont eu autant besoin
de l'Europe jamais ils n'ont autant
souffert jamais ils n'ont fait autant
d'efforts et c'est maintenant qu'on
déciderait de les aider moins silence au
pauvres parce que de toute façon ils
n'ont pas les moyens politiques de dire
non monsieur le Président accepter un
compromis élaboré sur de telles bases ce
serait prétendre faire l'Europe de la
solidarité à commencé par l'Europe
sociale pendant toute la durée de votre
avec le budget européen de Monsieur
Cameron de Monsieur Cameron quel
socialiste pourrait l'accepter qui de
nous pourrait l'accepter le groupe PPE
lui ne l'acceptera pas je vous
remercie monsieur le Président s'il vous
plaît
bien monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés je vourrais
d'abord vous remercier pour la qualité
de ce débat pour la franchise des
échanges et pour l'utilité je crois de
notre discussion en entendant monsieur
lamassour je me
disais que on demande à un socialiste
d'empêcher que les conservateurs fassent
un mauvais
budget je vous remercie pour votre
confiance mais elle révèle tant de
défiance pour ne pas dire tant de
distance à l'égard des gouvernements que
vous soutenez dans vos pays
respectifs parce que je dois quand même
informer le
Parlement les socialistes soci démocrate
sont très minoritaires au au sein du
Conseil européen et donc j'ai bien
entendu votre message mais si d'ici
jeudi vous pouvez le transmettre à vos
chefs de gouvernement et à vos chefs de
partis respectifs ce sera
heureux mais je prends un engagement
vis-à-vis de vous tout au long du
européen je ne cesserai de citer Joseph
d Al lamassour monsieur verstad si c'est
nécessaire pour les autres pardonnez-moi
je crains que votre renfort soit
inutile mais je pourrais me satisfaire
de cette situation et en même temps ce
ne serait pas
responsable je suis chef
d'État je représente la France à la
table du conseil européen et je n'y vais
pas pour exprimer
d'avance un refus
ou espérer un
échec mon devoir c'est de chercher le
compromis parce que je souhaite que
l'Europe puisse donner la meilleure
image qui soit c'estàd 27 chefs d'État
et de gouvernement entendant le
Parlement
européen constatant l'état de la
croissance voyant le doute qui existe
dans les opinions publiques prendre les
décisions nécessaires donc je viens
chercher un accord on me dit il est
difficile voire impossible du côté du
Royaume-Uni mais pourquoi un pays
pourrait décider à la place des 26
autres je pense même qu'au dernier
Conseil européen il était possible
d'arriver à un
accord et que dans un souci de laisser
les uns et les les autres dire que
l'échec était finalement une victoire
nous avons laissé faire et après nous
constatons que ça devient plus difficile
de faire
l'accord je pense que nous pouvons
convaincre parce que beaucoup de pays et
vous l'avez dit pas forcément pour de
bonnes raisons ou de bons motifs veulent
garder leurs chèqu et leurs rabais et
donc la
menace de l'échec peut être un facteur
favorable à la lucidité et à la prise de
conscience je souhaite un accord parce
que je considère que dans une démocratie
et elle est là vous êtes ses
représentants il est bon que vous
puissiez juger l'action des chefs d'État
et de gouvernement et donc ce qu'ils
auront trouvé c'est vrai je ne peux pas
vous dire le contraire que beaucoup la
plupart même des chefs d'État et de
gouvernement viennent défend défendre
autant l'intérêt national que l'intérêt
européen et parfois davantage l'intérêt
national que l'intérêt européen mais je
ne laisserai pas dire que la France en
tout cas la France d'aujourd'hui serait
prête à sacrifier les politiques de
croissance pour défendre simplement la
politique agricole commune parce que ce
n'est pas vrai parce que la politique
agricole commune va voir ses crédits
diminuer par rapport à ce qui était la
proposition de la Commission parce que
ça engendrera nécessairement des
restructurations difficiles
dans un secteur qui est essentiel pour
nos territoires je ne laisserai pas dire
que nous voulons remettre en cause les
politiques de croissance parce que nous
avons été pas seuls mais les premiers à
dire que la priorité maintenant devait
être à la croissance et je constate
qu'effectivement la facilité c'est de
mettre des coupes là où il y a l'avenir
qui est en cause la recherche la
connectique les infrastructures
l'énergie
deuxème réflexion je ne serai pas plus
long parce que je veux répondre à nos
amis britanniques qui ont pour la France
je le vois toujours les mêmes yeux de
chimen mais c'est une vieille histoire
que nous avons
ensemble je REM pas au général de gale
que vous auriez d soutenir à
l'époque
mais pas aller jusque là mais je vais
vous dire simplement les choses il nous
arrive d'être d'accord avec David
Cameron d'abord moi je salue le soutien
qu'il a apporté à l'intervention de la
France au Mali il a été le premier il
était le premier même à proposer des
avions et des matériel et donc je
n'auraai pas aujourd'hui l'attitude
grossière qui serait de
caricaturer un responsable politique et
un pays merci au Royaume-Uni
et par ailleurs je constate
qu'effectivement David Cameron est pour
le mariage pour tous ce qui facilite
forcément la discussion en France de ce
sujet je veux
répondre
au questions qui m'ont été adressées par
rapport à des enjeux majeurs pour
l'Europe je veux parler des
jeunes nous sommes un continent qui
vieillit nous n sommes un continent où
la natalité est
aujourd'hui faible en tout cas
insuffisante et nous mettons en cause
par nos politiques par nos choix la
place des jeunes dans nos sociétés je
considère que s'il y a un seul sujet qui
mérite que nous nous rassemblions tous y
compris pour la préparation de ce budget
c'est la place de la jeunesse en
Europe quand je dis la place de la jeun
c'est pas seulement les programmes
Erasmus les échanges universitaires les
mobilités de chercheurs essentiel c'est
aussi pour la jeunesse précarisée pour
la jeunesse pauvre pour la jeunesse qui
ne connaît pas la chance de pouvoir
suivre un enseignement supérieur et qui
a l'impression que l'Europe ne s'occupe
pas d'elle et donc nous devons dans ce
budget nous verrons ce qu'il sera faire
qu'il y ait un dispositif exceptionnel
pour les jeunes et qui fera que dans
tous les pays d'Europe au-delà de ce qui
aura été décidé dans l'Union nous
puissions accompagner ces orientations
pour permettre qu'aucun jeune ne soit
sans solution c'estàdire sans formation
sans qualification sans insertion sans
emploi parce que le risque de rupture il
n'est pas simplement civique il est
générationnel et qu'à un moment il y a
une jeunesse qui se met contre
l'évolution d'une
société je veux également
indiquer que
sur la politique de change nous ne
pouvons pas constater simplement
l'préciation de l'euro et nous en
désoler ou nous en réjouir tout dépend
des positions de chacun nous devons
avoir une politique de change elle est
prévue par les traités
elle ne dépend pas que de la Banque
centrale européenne c'est le rôle aussi
des gouvernements dans la zone euro que
de dire quelle priorité n voul accorder
à la monnaie et qu'il y a un paradoxe
c'est vrai de demander des efforts de
compétitivité à des pays et en mêmes de
le rchérir le prix de leur exportation
et ainsi d'empêcher tout rétablissement
de la balance des paiements ou de la
balance commerciale donc cette politique
de change nous devrons un moment ou un
autre nous en
saisir je veux terminer
par la question de Strasbourg puisquelle
a été
posée je connais
ici la diversité des
positions mais je ne défends pas
simplement Strasbourg parce que c'est
dans le traité je défends Strasbourg
capitale européenne parce que c'est
l'histoire qui nous rappelle le rôle de
Strasbourg parce
que c'est
vrai nous avons célébré
50e anniversaire du traité entre la
France et l'Allemagne et que Strasbourg
faisait partie de la réconciliation
entre nos deux pays je parle de
Strasbourg parce que c'est l'histoire et
c'est l'avenir de l'Europe parce qu'il y
a des villes qui représentent
symboliquement ce qu'est l'Europe je ne
défends pas Strasbourg simplement parce
que c'est en France parce que finalement
il y a d'autres sièges de l'Europe qui
sont dans d'autres pays je défend
Strasbourg parce que c'est l'Europe et
si on ne pense pas que Strasbourg peut
être le siège du Parlement européen
alors le doute s'installe sur les
convictions européennes de chacun queles
que soi les difficultés matérielles que
vous pouvez rencontrer merci en tout cas
de m'avoir reçu ici à Strasbourg au
siège du Parlement
européen
vous avez donc suivi en direct en
intégralité sur les Chaîne Parlementaire
cette séance plinière du parlement
européen en présence du président de la
République François Hollande le chef de
l'État qui a fait un discours d'une
trentaine de minutes puis a répondu aux
questions des